um I will ask the government's officer
to read out the domestic arrangements
and the fire regulations before we
start thank you chair morning please
ensure that you main social distance in
from all other persons whilst in the
chamber and in the communal areas please
ensure that you wear a face covering at
all times unless you are sitting down or
if you exempt from doing so and that you
use the hand sanitizer and wipes
provided please do not interrupt other
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speaking if you are
attending the meeting to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave please ensure your
mobile phones are on silent or switched
off we'll be using the EV voting for
this meeting on the modern gov app so
please could members make sure they're
log Lo in and ready to use the app if
you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via a fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point if
switch Town Football ground follow the
signs directing you to the fire exits at
each end of the floor do not enter the
atrium if you are in the atrium at the
time of the alarm follow the signs to
the nearest exit use the stairs not the
lifts and do not re-enter the building
until it's told to safe to do so the
council members of the public and the
Press May record film photograph or
broadcast pass this meeting when the
press and the public are not lawfully
excluded thank you chair thank you CLA
just to introduce the offic is present
today for lisbo chief planning officer
our legal advisor in De
pre is our heritage officer here not yet
okay case officers we have Elizabeth
flood and Vincent pierce with us at the
moment and our government's officers CLA
Philpot and Council award is joining as
as a ward member on a slightly later
application I understand there's been a
number of table papers including one
this morning would you like a little bit
of time to read through those um those
of you who are not speed readers perhaps
you would perhaps if I give you five
minutes or are you all
happy all happy we'll be substituting
and we are also waiting on the arrival
of council mcro thank
you any Declarations of Interest
councelor
Parker there we go thank you chair um
yeah in respect of DC
21745 the slaughter house and land
adjacent to kku Hill um I've previously
declared a pecuniary interest in this
item um Chair by virtue of the fact I've
got business arrangements with the um
applicant agent so in the interest of
consistency um I will do the same again
and withdraw from that item chair that's
in order thank you thank you thank you
counc
P any
other counc
jansson in regard to the um passage Lane
application which is
24477 I have um already I've offered
support and um advice to the applicant
so I probably would best set that one
out but we'll speak as a world member
if possible yes and we'll we'll double
check that with you as we start that
application okay thank you any
other right thank you
um confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 1st of December
anying points regarding the accuracy of
these
minutes nope in that case can I have a
proposer
please Council Osborne second Council
beer thank you
I'll get the government's offic to
conduct a vote if I can get back into my
machine thank you chair members if you
open your app and go to the plus sign in
the stop top right hand
corner select attendance and voting this
vote is now in
progress
thank you members chair that's nine
votes for and one abstention that's
carried that's carried thank you just to
note that Council mcro has
arrived thank you Council
M Mr Mr chairman can when councelor a
has sorted himself out can we just check
he hasn't got any declarations M yes
indeed
sorry just confirm you have
no pecuniary or non pecuniary interest
in any of the planning applications
today I'm the ward member for the last
application but I believe that's a
non-pecuniary
interest thank
you so that's pass thank
you any notifications of
petitions non received chair any
requests for site
inspections non received thank you very
much so we'll move on sorry oh sorry
counc Parker uh well I'm not sure if
it's a request as such sh chair but I'm
just wondering obviously we've um we've
had notification that the Bell View um
application um in respect to Churchill
has come forward this week um given the
substantial public interest I just
wonder if that is something that we
ought to be um considering for for for
site
visit second can ask the chief planning
officer
that
um chairman yes I mean it's obviously
early days in our considerations of
planning Authority so we we tend to at
least allow the uh the consultation to
have uh taken place so we can gaar some
initial views before taking members to
site because sometimes they flush out
things of interest um it's it's not
unreasonable for the committee to
express a a desire to have that reported
back once once we've undertaken and got
got that in hand to uh guide members on
a site visit so yes it's it's c
appropriate to flag the interest if I
can put it like that
CH thank
you any other site inspections anyone to
discuss no in that case we'll move on to
the first planning application that's
Land South of town Hill Lane East of
frogo Lane Hadley I will invite the case
officer Vincent Pierce to introduce this
application to the committee Vincent
thank you chair for good morning members
and guests as the chair says first item
dc95 419 Land South of Mill
Road Tower Mill Lane and ipswitch Road
in Hadley and this is a hybrid
application so we have an element that
is effectively a full application we
have another element that's
outlin as always this presentation is
merely meant to reinforce and supplement
the report that you have before you
Hadley sits at the top of our settlement
hierarchy as a a town and urban area so
it is one of the most sustainable
locations in the
district I'm sure everyone is aware
where Hadley sits if we go north from
colist and west from ipswitch where
those lines intersect is
Hadley in terms of the local context
surrounded by a number of uh villages
principally approached by the
a1071 and the
B70
the first element we're going to look at
this morning is the full application and
that is for 273 dwellings of which 96
are affordable
dwellings the land shown there in red is
entirely
residential and that is the full
component
so that
jumped y the next bit we'll look at in
the second half of this presentation is
the outline element which includes
largely employment uses but also
includes a site for early years facility
as required by suffk County Council so
the brown land is the employment land on
the other side of what will be a a spine
Road and the area colored yellow is
where the early year site is
proposed very quick fly through I'm sure
you're all very familiar with with
Hadley but as you you can see at
approaching the bottom of the screen is
what's known as Phase 1 B that's a
development by Pimon comprising
dwellings so this site sits on the east
side of Hadley and is presently
connected to the town center and a range
of facilities via Town Mill Lane so if
we just superimpose the application
site as you can see to Mill Lane running
horizontally across that picture goes
right into Into the Heart of of
Hadley open Countryside very little
vegetation it is technically the third
phase of development known as Weaver's
Meadow so originally the outline
permission covered the area in red we've
seen the completion of phase one some
time ago phase 1B is currently under
construction the land in Blue on this uh
slide is land that will come to the
council for a pound and that will be for
its own
employment uses and developments and
phase three sits to the south of those
three
elements in terms of constraints the
site is effectively unconstrained in the
sense that we always understand it
Heritage assets are a long way from the
site we have a brid way and footpath
connecting to the northern edge of the
site and that will be a key part of the
connectivity that we look at
later there is no flood risk in terms of
fluvial
orial
flooding and as you've seen from the
report the site is already allocated in
the adopted development plan and it
continues to be um promoted as a
residential employment allocation in the
jlp so basic layout is as shown on the
screen so in order to access
it Ellen alus Avenue will be extended to
create a spine Road from which there
will be three connection points into the
residential
development effectively these will then
serve two principal Loop roads off of
which
spring a variety of house
types becoming less and less um
engineered right down to private drives
as you get to the of the development so
there is a clear Road hierarchy within
the scheme the central portion I'm now
showing in green is effectively a
carfree Village Green and members who
were on the committee when we looked at
1B will already remember that's a
feature we secured in the previous phase
and is working very well so that's the
Hub um pedestrian cyclon Hub with houses
looking onto
it that's the access from the 1071 IP
Swit Road roundabout into the
site this will be the only way of
getting into that
development quick look along turill Lane
it isn't intended to use turill Lane for
any vehicular access to this
development so that is currently a
bridal way the scheme improves funding
to make improvements to the surface of
tower Mill
Lane um but that will remain a principle
pedestrian
cycle access into the Town
Center quick scan so there we are in the
blue
dot looking East and we'll just quickly
scan back towards Hadley as you can see
the site is open in terms of
the boundary to town Mill
Lane and it's largely the Open Fields
with a scattering
of
hedro
the scheme is actually uh proposing two
tiger Crossings and I'm not sure whether
we've seen those in babber we've
certainly got some now in mids
suffk they will be positioned broadly
where the bridal way will cross the
spine Road and adjacent to the Village
Green to provide a connection to the
employment land what is a tiger
Crossing it combines
The Pedestrian element the sort of zeer
Crossing element with a specific Lane
for Cycles so effectively it
accommodates both types of uh user in a
segregated Corridor and that is
something that's being promoted more and
more by our colleagues at suffk County
but also on a spine road with good cycle
connections this becomes an integral
part of the connectivity
Network as we talk about connectivity
let's just look at some of the basic
principles of the scheme so we have the
Village Green from which radiate a
number of pedestrian and cycle routes
through green spaces those green spaces
connect to other green spaces beyond the
site to the north but also link through
into the employment land and
Beyond so that provides an easy way for
residents in Hadley to walk to work
cycle to work within the new employment
area and also access land to the north
this layout has been carefully designed
to allow that development to be extended
to the southeast on land that is
presently allocated within the jlp so
rather than turn its back on what will
be a future phase we've tried to create
a central hub from which radiate a
number of
connections so you could easily see how
that open space could be expanded and
create a much larger Village Green being
that residents of this development will
have to Cross Roads very
infrequently and in terms of the
position of the early years site which
is down here you could see that that's
starting to form a bit of a community
Hub that is very accessible by by
foot all of those access routes and
green spaces are well surveilled by a
decent houses we have no back fences
onto those open spaces so it should be
very secure and
safe looking at the jlp plan
la28 there's the application site that
is the land that would come forward in
future years under the joint local
plan and that Green Dot represents the
Hub we're beginning to create if this is
approved in this
location so you can see how that would
sit right in the middle of that
development ideally positioned for roots
to radiate out for pedestrians and
cyclists and of course that would then
link back into Hadley so we've got the
primary school the high school Hadley
pool and Leisure the High Street all the
facilities within the town would be an
easy walking and cycling distance and
those routes will be segregated from the
road wherever we can achieve
that drainage is carefully thought out
with a series of uh basins and swes that
connect those our colleagues at suffer
County floods are very happy with that
that
proposal in terms of the house types
again this is we have worked with Pimon
to use a range of house types that are
pushing
the design boundaries in a way that we
did on phase 1B so we have a great deal
of interesting detail sizes
forms each of the on that screen you can
see right in the middle is effectively
two Gateway units to another road that
um cuts back from the village screen so
what we've tried to do is identify key
Corners in order to Aid legibility and
you'll notice that we've got walls in
all prominent positions no fences and
where we turn a corner those normally
blank elevations are fully elevated to
create interest and allow
surveillance
again some of that detail you can see
string courses Stone
Sills flat brick arches
coins significant amount of interesting
detail and that that's repeated
throughout the
development that in that one I spotted
that needs to be a wall so we'll make
sure that's a wall that slip through the
the net so there's are two examples of
corner turning units hope hopefully you
all agree that that's far more
interesting than seeing a blank flank
wall but it also allows surveillance of
the open space that
sits beside it so we're very pleased
that Pimon have um worked with us to
agree this level of of detail I think it
will complement phase 1B and in some
ways surpass it and that's what we
always try and do each time we have a
large development is build on something
that we thought was good before
constantly trying to raise the design
standard
we've also got a number of units and
members will have seen this on other
schemes where potentially that is a
three-bedroom unit but it's also a twoed
with office so the area in yellow we
would ensure through condition that room
is fully connected to super fast
Broadband um and something that's coming
out of coid is that a number of National
Health Builders are working with us to
create these more flexible spaces in
people's
homes um if the prospect is with Co that
something we're going to have to live
with there may be occasions where
working from home becomes more of a norm
and then we're just encouraging
developers to put that bit of
flexibility in to make it more bearable
for anyone who has to work at home
rather than sit at the kitchen table
potentially they have us a room that's
ready for action should it be
required Bungalows we have 12 Bungalows
uh spread across the
development few artist Impressions so
from the top the northern Corner looking
over over that Lagoon that will
essentially be dry most of the the year
we are suggesting a condition to enhance
the Landscaping recreational
purposes looking across the Village
Green as you can see no cars cars have
been designed out um extensive Wild
Flower Meadow planting and trees well
surveilled all the houses looking out
onto it and some interesting what I
would almost call Village house types
we've tried to
create something that doesn't look like
an ordinary anywhere estate something we
were successful in Long mford members
will remember that
application something we're achieving I
think we're achieving that here with
bimon and again another view across open
space that's a view from the spine
Road affordable housing again very well
dispersed so we've got a cluster of 12
10 9 in the northwest corner in the
middle of the site again some clustering
either side of one of those Road
roads and at the southern
end that's 96 units the majority of
which will be affordable rented which is
something that uh we need within the
district to cater for the high number of
people on the housing register and of
course we are trying to deliver
127 affordable housing units a year to
meet the
demand parking we've work very hard with
Pimon and they have um cooperated with
us they are aware of the committee's
position on Triplex parking we now only
have three sites where Triplex parking
exists on any of the main road Network
we have a few also on private drives but
we have on this scheme a significant
amount of of visitor parking and I know
that's something members have pushed us
to achieve in on other sites and bimman
have embraced that um principle so you
can see there's a good spread of visitor
parking that's on street parking and
again throughout the estate so we are
very pleased with the parking provision
as are our colleagues at saf
County in terms of
landscaping we have worked with Pim and
our own team to create a
a rich mix of indigenous
species shown on the on the screen a lot
of tree planting we've got some 237 new
trees of
which 31 will be extra heavy standards
so they'll be something in the region of
10 m tall when they're they're planted
so subject to management plan um they
should take very well and provide
instant
impact the open space will also be
adopted by the council and as you know
babber is beginning
to it has re reevaluated its position
and is now Keen to adopt open space
where it serves a strategic
recreational function and this site has
a very large area of open space and it
is something that our public round team
do want to take on so when we get to the
section 106 agre section you'll notice
that there's a significant financial
contribution to the council to assist
with the long-term maintenance of that
open
space and again all hedge RS and Native
planting throughout the the scheme just
to give you a sample of what that might
look like here's an extract from one of
the detailed landscape plans so the
yellow is wildf flower Meadow and you
can see there is a rich um I was going
to say scattering but it's probably a
bit more than the scattering there
almost like a a cops forming and that
could be developed over time once the
land is in our ownership we could of
course supplement that tree planting in
line with the council's approach to
tackling the climate
emergency the spine Road will have an an
Avenue of fdate horn beams a vertical
upward growing so that would be quite a
striking feature and that Pro would
provide Autumn color as
well and as you can see there is a wide
Verge again to create this sense of
openness the buildings are set back
they're all looking out onto that spine
Road and again more of the examples of
the
planting as I said earlier we are not
entirely satisfied with the Landscaping
scheme within the drainage basins and we
are suggesting further condition
requiring some addition
information because we have an ideal
opportunity to put um Wetland species in
there that will actually keep the water
clean and uh fresh and also we're
looking to put in species that encourage
Wetland wildlife and we're not quite
there yet but we are satisfied that with
bim's cooperation we can deal with that
by
condition and here we have t
Lane and the development touches the
edge of town Mill Lane and you may say
well at the moment Town Mill Lane is is
a Country Lane that runs through fields
and here we've got development now
encroaching onto the the edge of T Mill
Lane but in truth all of the land around
it is
allocated for residential development
the local plan identifies TL Lane as the
principal connection to the town center
and the policy us to make improvements
to that one of the concerns that's been
expressed locally is that town Mill Lane
might at the moment be quite open it's
unlit and might be unsafe during hours
of Darkness what we're actually
achieving here with the the housing is
excellent surveillance and when you
think that the whole of Weaver's Meadow
could be accessing this route by foot
and by bike to get into town I actually
think there are real benefits in terms
of the safety of users from having
development that comes close to town
Mill Lane and we don't actually have a
high hedro running along that um entire
length of of Frontage it is what it is
it will be a central Corridor running
through what is up to 600 houses
ultimately and if we look at it in that
light I think this is an entirely
appropriate um way to deal with
providing safety
in terms of residential immunity here
you can see the blue and orange
triangles are the closest properties and
you can see that effectively they are
joined by open space so there's no
Prospect of harm to residential amenity
from
overlooking and the
like again where this phase would meet
Phase 1 B we would have have a large
area of open space drainage basin so
again no risk of harm to residential
immunity durrant's Farm which is
accessed via terill Lane what we're
suggesting is a condition that includes
a 20 M Landscape buffer around the edge
of the site which would provide further
privacy for the occupiers of of Durant's
Farm of course we don't have the detail
for this element because this is the uh
employment
section and we have other safeguards
that I'll come on to so if we now look
at the employment element which is the
eastern half of the
site everything within that uh red line
with the white core we are suggesting a
condition to limit the amount of
employment use to 5.5 hectares so that
it Accords with the uh local plan and
ensures that our economic uh strategy
set out out in the plan is not
prejudiced by an over supply of
employment land in this particular
location you'll have noticed on the
drawing that there is a
connection that appears to run into the
residential component that's currently
under construction phase 1B throughout
discussions with piman we have agreed
that that can't be a general through
access and could only be used as an
emergency access or bus gate and I just
flag on the screen that I noticed put in
the presentation together that the
wording
here whoops here might be open to some
confusion because it actually says major
Access Road looping required to access
employment land we do show bards here
across the road and here but to avoid
any confusion I am suggesting we have a
condition that says for the avoidance of
doubt that connection can can only be
used as an emergency access and or bus
gate and is not available for through
traffic is what we wouldn't want
necessarily
is the spine Road within phase one to be
used as some sort of R run to access
this corner of the employment
land and there we have it in a bit more
detail you can see how that will be
closed off in any event with
bards the employment Parcels here we
show in the light brown and this is the
20 M Landscape buffer that I'm
suggesting I'm also suggesting that we
should have a condition that
encourages an employment developer a
commercial developer to provide lower
scale units in the zones where I've
shown them in black for the very obvious
reason that we don't necessarily want
High warehouses fronting the spine Road
immediately opposite twostory dwellings
and that's something that you'll have
noted from the table papers that our
Economic Development colleagues have
have expressed concern about and it's I
agree with them entirely and we can deal
with that by condition we'd also have
control through the reserve matters when
those details came in but I think it's
advisable to let anyone thinking about
purchasing the employment land to know
right from the start that we think these
ought to be lower lower scaled
units here we have the early years
land much needed facility something
supported by our colleagues at County
but we are requiring a piece of extra
piece of land um to provide off street
parking something that colleagues at
suffer County have
requested there it is in a bit more
detail and that will sit it right at the
Hub and the Heart of this new community
as Weaver's Meadow expands in terms of
section 106 it is set out in the report
but I do want to go through in a little
bit of detail just so that we're clear
what it is we're achieving for the
community so we get 96 dwellings the
majority of which are affordable rented
we get a sports facilities contribution
of just under 100,000 and it has been
suggested that perhaps had Hadley Rugby
Club uh which is looking to expand might
benefit from that contribution but it
isn't um necessarily earmarked for the
Rugby Club but it is identified for
sports facilities
expansion there is or there will be a
neighborhood area equipped I've got
those around the wrong way it's
neighborhood equipped area play neep
with a contribution of 91,000 so a neep
is at the top end of the um types of
play area that you can get so it caters
for all ranges of young
people the open space maintenance sum
61,000 so that would come to babber
District Council to manage the open
space and we get two contributions
towards ecological
mitigation in total that's some 8
148,000 if you effectively if you price
the affordable housing even at 76,000
per dwelling that comes to 7.2 million
pound worth of affordable
housing in terms of elements that are
more um attuned with our colleagues at
County Benton Street Improvement
50,000 members who know Hadley very well
will know that not that long ago there
were a series of exhibition events
within Hadley to try and identify
improvements that could be secured for
Benton
Street this scheme would deliver £50,000
that would help fund improvements to
Benton
Street primary school expansion a
significant sum again an even bigger sum
for secondary school land contributions
and expansion of six forms
the early year site for a pound the
build cost for the early Year's
facility 450 odd th000 travel plan
contributions public rights away
libraries
health and that's something that people
are Keen to say are we actually securing
expanded GP facilities well on this one
we are SEC the health authority have
asked us to secure
1573 and that's what we have agreed with
Bim
and also we've secured enhanced bus
service and I want to explain this a
little bit originally we were looking
for a significant commuted
sum for the county to help deliver a new
service but what we've secured is a
commitment from Pimon to fund that new
bus service that would serve this site
the employment land and connect the
adjacent
villages in line with a specification to
be agreed with the Trans local
Transportation
Authority so the county provides the
specification the number of buses the
routes and piman will then deliver that
service with a direct payment to the
operator broadly speaking that's some
two and a half million pounds of
contributions uh that would go into
effectively into the local community in
a variety of ways as shown on that
screen so our position as officers is
that we are recommending approval of
both elements the full and the outline
proposal subject to First securing a
section 106 agreement to secure all the
items that I've gone through and then
delegate to the chief planning officer
to Grant conditional planning permission
and I've set out on the updated papers
some amended conditions that I'm also
suggesting on that basis chair my
presentation is complete thank
you thank you any questions for the
officer we'll kick off with councelor
Busby you got your hand up there very
quickly
oh thanks J uh Vince can you go back to
the slides that you got the one with the
section
106 contributions on
there the 2.5 million um this site is
not due for any sill
contributions yeah what would the sill
contributions have been roughly had it
been I mean I don't know the answer to
that well I I thought roughly 180
houses um excluding the affordable
ones 20,000 a house you're looking about
3.6 million so I mean the 2.5 million
looks really really generous and if
you're like onerous on the developer but
it's not as doesn't seem as onerous as a
a Sil contribution in there so I think
we we ought to take that it's a fair
point Council ofby but of course course
we got the
2.5 plus the
878 so that's it's almost 3.5 and then
what I haven't costed out is the value
of the enhanced bus service and
originally we were looking at
400,000 pounds so there are elements in
there that I haven't been able to cost
so to be fair to you I didn't explain
why I've grayed out certain bits you
know um that land would also have a
value we're getting it for a pound the
county will be getting it for pound but
at uh if it was
300,000 an acre that's a significant
effectively cost that we have saved so
if you put all of that into the pot it
does get much closer possibly even
higher than the figure that you've
suggested okay but that's it's good
because I I think people would want to
know why we weren't claiming sill on it
uh and but that's sill is that's what we
would have used s for presumably it is
yes
thank
you counc Osborne you had a
question thank you Mr chairman just one
about the enhanced uh bus services uh
going to be supplied uh monies from Pim
development how long do you expect for
that to to last because uh 400,000
sounds a lot but uh how long is it going
to
be
please we have been looking at a figure
of 5 years but obviously at the end of
the day that's something for the
Transportation Authority the idea behind
it is that if you can get the
implementation of the new service right
in terms of the number of houses that
it's that are available to use it and
that you give new purchases effectively
a travel pass after five years the
service will either be self-funding or
will prove unviable and stops but if
we're looking at 600 houses I'd like to
to think we might be able to get a
scheme that actually pays for itself but
it you know who
knows be you were
next we hidden it
up thank thank you Mr chairman um I
think just on the point of the two and a
half million you're quite right um it is
very generous of them but I think it's
worth remembering that at the end of the
day it's the house purchaser that pays
that so the KnockOn effect is you know
they could be cheaper but that is sorry
I've got two questions um on slide 27 I
think it was you sh um the third bedroom
being used as a office or bedroom um can
I just be assured again that that third
room isn't so small that you really
can't get a bed in there and a wardrobe
um because it's very easy for a
developer to say the third bedroom is
now being you available for office and
you can work from home and credit to all
that but they're usually so small you
can't do anything else with them you
can't get a bed in there you can't swing
a cat round so that was the first one if
you can answer that and secondly I think
it's slide 44 which show Green open
spaces can I be assured that you've
you've got some sort of commitment from
the developers that um there will be
some sort of uh deterrent to stop cars
from parking on grass verges Open Spaces
which I think you've picked up but often
we have complaints from residents and we
say it when we drive around these
Estates that it's in front of their um
Garden there's a bit of f just R run
along the front and because they can't
they've got a third car they can't get
it off the on the the dri so they stick
it on the path and the fge and good
knows what what precautions have you got
in place for that thank you thank you
canoun beer two excellent points the
third room is big enough to be a bedroom
so what we're encouraging is just the
installation of that technology so that
it's truly flexible so it could be used
a bed would go in there and it would
make a third bedroom um in terms of the
deterrence it is something that we've
seen you've probably seen it in cornard
it's seen every on this scheme we have
got the knee rail you know the the foot
high with the diamond shape post all
around those Open Spaces in order to
prevent unauthorized um parking so it
should be entirely safe for the users of
that open space and will look much
better because it won't be littered with
cars everywhere all over the Green
Space just follow on from that and would
this be picked up as the respons
responsibility of the management by bab
District Council that if you know these
got damaged knocked down removed or or
10 years down the road they've rotted or
F down somebody's got to be responsible
and management companies are not very
good I would hope can cancels a much
better once that land is adopted we
would then be responsible for those Nal
fences and that's something that the
£61,000 would help
towards
thank you Mr chairman um couple of
points we've made a big thing about this
being an allocated site Etc uh within
the current local plan of course
effectively it's not in the new joint
local plan for the simple reason that
the inspectors said that we've got to go
back and look at strategic housing
allocation Etc in from almost from
square one because at the moment there
are enough permissions granted within
bab to fulfill housing requirements for
next for the length of the plan anyway
so strictly speaking um the new joint
local plan um doesn't have any weight
anyway uh in this case
um has it been considered that the
employ the provision of employment land
on this site as well as as
housing uh is potentially
a a back door for more housing as per
the other part of the weav Meadow site
where we effectively had to take over
part of the employment land because Pim
said we are housing developers not
Industrial Park developers and
consequently they got more houses and we
ended up with a piece of building land
which we haven't actually done anything
with yet uh so those the first points
and the other one on U slide 30 uh front
Gardens look about sort of uh 2 foot 6 3
foot perhaps deep
um where are the charging points for
residents uh because if they're going to
have electric cars then they need to
charge them up and on that point what
has been put forward to the County
Council to stress the fact that Benton
Street isn't just a problem
between the war memorial and the 30 mph
limit it's a problem all the way to the
a12 and to the junction onto the a12 and
these people are going to have to work
somewhere and that means either down the
1071 into whip switch which we all know
can be backed up to hint shim on in in
the mornings um or it'll be trying to
get something sorted out on uh Junction
31 of the
a12 thank you chairman yes just on the
join local plan I mean the uh published
letter from the inspectorate uh on the
joint local plan as we've said to
committee on many times the joint local
plan has limited weight and that remains
our position and that will be the same
both before uh and after this um and
until uh the resumption of that
examination hearing tomorrow I think we
are it will be wrong to conclude but
that's certainly what what is expected
to happen so just for the record that's
not yet a settled position on the
allocations but it's expected to happen
so the reality is simply to say uh The
Joint local plan has limited weight for
the purposes of this decision there is
uh a draft allocation proposed within it
and we say as as with the rest of the
joint local plan that has limited weight
but taking all the considerations in the
round we're recommending permission if I
hand over to uh Mr Pierce to pick up the
other points that's that's simply a a
technical point about jlb thank you
chairman could I just come back on that
part of it and say well I as I
understand stood the letter from the
planning inspectorate they were talking
about effectively splitting the local
plan in or the joint local plan in
half uh basically saying that one bit
was just about ready to go but the one
bit the bit regarding strategic housing
and everything else would have to start
uh almost from square one would take
over a year at least to uh to formulate
before
resubmission uh and that uh effectively
the meeting tomorrow was to effectively
agree that the local plan was taken in
two half
so so just to to confirm the position uh
it's expected to agree that Council
Hinton it hasn't been agreed and to that
extent we are in the world of
speculation about an outcome that will
happen as a consequence of tomorrow's
examination you are correct that the
intention is to split the plan so that
spo3 and lp1 for memory are uh taken
away for further uh review and uh
reconsideration but as we sit here today
that's not settled conclusively so as
with all the other things we work on
what the facts are today and what we're
describing what you and I talking about
is not yet a concluded
position thank you chair in in response
to your first point councelor Hinton I
understand your concern we did indeed uh
allow phase 1B for largely residential
when it was earmarked for employment at
the time we didn't have a five-year
housing land Supply so what we've
effectively done through this phase
phase two is to move the employment land
that was to have been 1B and pushed it
South so effectively it's still the same
employment land that's within the
adopted local plan CS6 but we've just
moved it South so in that sense it does
conform to CS6 we are still securing it
we are still intent
on having that delivered our economic
development team colleagues are very
supportive of the principle they have
identified significant demand for sites
in Hadley we fully expect this to come
forward for employment use but as you
know with your
experience we can't actually deliver it
ourselves unless we own it it is
something I had hoped we might be able
to secure but who gives land to the
Council of that size for a pound
nobody um we fully EXP expect it to come
forward for employment land and
irrespective of the JP it does conform
to the adopted development plan in terms
of the electric vehicles you're quite
right where we've secured The Village
Green obviously there is no road in
front of it but what we have are parking
spaces to the rear in very small parking
courts each of those will be
serviced in terms of EV capability by
the correct electrical connections so
that residents can provide their own
electric vehicle charging point points
to the rear where there are garages we
would fully expect that to have the EV
Point built in it's something we've
developed with Pimon on the previous
phase in terms of getting electric
vehicle charging to the parking courts
we can by condition make that a
requirement for 100% of the units to
have access
to that sort of level of connectivity
and it is something I'm proposing so
that will be covered
counselor you are next
thank you chair
um the adoption of the Open Spaces by B
District Council public realm is
obviously a good one and you mentioned
about does that include the water Meadow
and the SS areas on these
sites there is a dividing line between
where our adoption would stop and the
drainage Authority would be responsible
for the actual Lagoon so we wouldn't be
responsible for the wit elements of
those Basin the only reason is every
time we have an application uh for
development it does worry me slightly
about the safety we we we're providing
uh developments that encourages families
and children and everybody to play but
I'm always concerned about the
protection of small children around
water collection points
um can you sort of advise me on what
measures are usually taken thank you
um within this District well within the
county our colleagues require I've I've
provided I haven't got it on this um
presentation but effectively you have to
have a one in four slope Roser say that
one in three is acceptable so our County
colleagues actually want a a slacker
slope than rosper consider safe then you
have a flat table and then you have
another slope and a flat table and the
point of a one in four ramp is that
anyone can pull themselves out stand up
on the flat bit depending on where the
water is on this one we'd have a whole
series of these so that you could always
get out easily but also some of these
have a a branch star fence around the
perimeter so it's as safe as we can get
it as I say most of the year it will be
dry but again the standards we're
applying through our colleagues at the
county are tougher than Roser advocate
so we think we're
doing doing well in terms of safety and
at this point we we fully
understand thank you thank
you thank you chair um as I understand
it the Open
Spaces um the drainage in the roads from
Phase One have still not been adopted
apparently public realm say they're not
up to
scratch and um that was built several
years ago so what Assurance firstly what
assurances have we got that
um specimen are going to make the are
not going to do the same with this phase
mean phase one's not ready yet I mean
this is a long way it's a long way down
the
line um also other points um you
mentioned about having a condition on
employment land so the
low
um commercial buildings opposite the
spine row but then surely if you got
where houses behind them they're still
going to be visible to the houses along
the spine road
so um a couple of other points um you
say you're going to try to get 100% EV
charging but PIM in their sustainability
statements are offering about 185 houses
or 185 points and I wondered where and
also could you clarify how many houses
are going to have um PV panels I think
you said six in your
report
thanks if we
start with your questions and work
backwards certainly I think all of those
can be asked of our guests from bimon in
terms of will they deliver and what they
say they're going to deliver that's
almost out of my hands and I'm not going
to dwell on matters that relate to to
phase one but by all means ask them that
question
um you're right uh there are a very
small number of PV panels being proposed
you can ask bimon directly when it comes
to their turn in the chair their actual
intentions in terms of PB PV to see
whether that is the figure or it's moved
since I last spoke to them um they are
aiming for
19% um energy saving so higher than our
10% policy I'm sure they have an answer
and I'm sure they'll be delighted to
respond to that that question in terms
of electric vehicle charging you're
right puman haven't um offered to
provide a 100%
um delivery what I'm suggesting is that
we have a condition that says that's
what we want and that's what they've got
to provide it is
becoming almost the norm with some house
builders that we deal with now to
provide 100% or at least get the
electricity to those parking courts so
that people can install electric vehicle
charging I see no problem with that as a
condition and the first point which has
now gone out of my mind I did make a
note and I had a great answer can you
remind me councelor jerson of your first
point point was regarding the Open
Spaces and
the um on the on phase one I think oh
well I have dealt with yeah and the
other point was about the warehous is at
the back of the um no good point the
warehouses I think if sitting in this
room if you look at that far
war and that's quite close to you you
might think oh that's that's not really
a human scale but if we have something
that's half that size in front of it
what it actually does is if you imagine
that wall being where the chief planning
officer in the chair is sitting that is
far more oppressive than being where it
is with a lower building in in front so
what we're trying to do is ensure that
the the Outlook from the house is as low
as possible what happens behind it
because your ey is always moving upwards
is
fine we can't have an employment Zone
that doesn't accommodate warehouses but
what we don't want are those warehouses
tall warehouses right on the road
Frontage where it is potentially harmful
to Outlook so we're just softening that
impact by pushing them further back into
the into the
site okay
thanks that's B yes you you want to to
get back in yeah sorry to come back Mr
chairman but on your point of the uh
parking courts and the electric charging
I'd like to know how many the um
developers providen so I'll ask them
that question in due course or they may
answer but um I'm concerned that if
people are parking in those parking
courts and there are some electric
charges are they allocated to certain h
hous
holds um presumably if if there's 10
spaces and you've got five or six houses
nearby they perhaps going to use them I
can understand that but what I'm
concerned about Mr chairman is that we
do get some people who end up with a car
parked right the back there that's not
taxed taken up as space or the wheels
are off the vehicle and it can't be
moved so no one else can use it is there
any provisions
to stop that because we we are
encountering that on our hous and
Estates now we don't want to go forward
knowing that and not putting something
in that can that we can have some powers
to get these removed because if they
clog all these um parking courts up and
they're behind the properties where no
one can see them um it defeats the
object of what we're trying to achieve
thank
you these will be private parking space
spes bit like having a car on your drive
but it's just around the the back but
each of the spaces each property will
have a number of spaces conveyed within
the title so I understand it and I'm
sure presuming will deal with it in the
title so there won't be a random you
just find the first space you can find
and park in it some of the parking
courts also have visitor
spaces what we could try and Achieve
with um Pim is that where we have
visitor spaces they come with a electric
charging point so that residents could
actually charge their car in the visitor
space and then move their car into their
own parking space But we would certainly
want very minimum to get the electric
supply to each of those parking spaces
so that somebody could put their own in
but great question let's ask P Simon how
they see that working but the answer is
they are
conveyed I I propose as
we I was going to suggest that we move
on to the uh developer because more and
more of the questions are being that way
I'm sure we can come back to Mr Price
with any other questions but I think as
so many at this stage are involving the
the developer and as we've got no local
Council representive ejector or
supporter the only person who wishes to
speak to us is Stuart mccadam and I
would suggest we start with him and and
then move on from there and we can
always come back to the officer if You'
got any more questions
St good morning chair and members of the
planning committee my name is Stuart
mccadam and I'm the planning manager for
Pimon homes in suffk I'm joined today by
my technical director Gary Lee and
between us we hope to be able to answer
some of these questions they may have
Hardley is identified as a key area of
growth for in the settlement's hierarchy
of the district and the proposals will
deliver employment land and homes in
accordance with the local plan site
allocation and will significantly
contribute to meeting the council's
housing and employment
needs the proposal includes 96
affordable units which are pepper ported
throughout the scheme and clusters and
are 10e blind the affordable mix has
been agreed with your housing officer of
the total number of units 47% are two
bed properties and a combined number of
two to three bed properties is
75% a significant number of amendments
have been secured through discussions
with your officers
a particular note as a considerable open
space throughout the site including the
Village Green which runs through the
heart of the development and extends
through to the employment site creating
a high quality carfree
environment the proposals provide a
series of interesting character areas
with landmar buildings and excellent
permeability is provided through the
site and Beyond to link with the
surrounding public right of way
Network improve safe pedestrian
connectivity to the town center will be
secured through a series of improvements
to terill Lane and the local bus service
will be enhanced and brought into the
site to create a highly sustainable
development and encourage residents to
use modes of Transport other than the
private car design improvements have
been achieved through the use of a wide
range of bricks render and tiles an
enhanced detail includes the
introduction of brick plants and banding
Corell details Stone cills and external
glazing bars the proposals provide for
increased sustainability measures across
the site by improving carbon reductions
in line with the emerging local plan
policy of
19% rather than the current adopted
policy requirement of 10% this will be
achieved through the provision of photov
Volta panels all dwellings with on plot
parking will be future proofed for EV
charging as well the parking courts
which will incorporate ducting and
drawrings to ensure that future
connections to the charging points can
be be achieved and Ultra fast Broadband
will also be provided to all the
homes a comprehensive section 106
package will provide significant
infrastructure benefits with in addition
to the usual health education Highway
requirements will provide a significant
amount of money towards sports
facilities hardle a neighborhood area of
play and off-site habitat mitigation
Pimon homes is a proven record and is
committed to the delivery of new homes
and and as a substantial owner of a
substantial part of the site with an
option to buy the remainder can deliver
the housing units well within 5 years to
help the council meet its housing
delivery
objectives we welcome the positive
officer recommendation which has been
achieved through collaborative working
and I hope that members can approve the
application thank you for affording me
the opportunity to speak to you this
morning answer James you go
first uh yeah really it's just a repeat
of the questions I put to the officer um
I understand that the the um from phase
one the Open Spaces the drains and RADS
are still not been adopted because
you've not completed the M standard and
I just wondered um what guarantees we
got that you're going to do that with
this phase and also I know that you've
um broken condition on noise where
you've done construction work on Sundays
and Bank Mondays previously and youve
our enforcement team have had to speak
to your um Constructors and I wondered
again what assuran is we going to have
that you won't repeat the same on on
this
development and then with regard to the
PV panels how many you actually going to
put in it says in the report you're only
putting in
six
for planning permission um so just be a
little bit careful please but perhaps if
youd like to to what you think you thank
you yeah I'm I'm quite happy to address
some of the well all of your issues
actually um albeit they're not for the
decision today or consideration but in
terms of the open space yes there were
issues in Phase One hold our hands up
and and accept that we are looking to
address them as it as it speaks as we
happen now and areas will be ones
they've been brought up to a c standard
adopted by U bber District Council as it
stands just now um we have reached an
agreement with the council that we will
pay their contractor to undertake these
Works to get them up to that standard so
that they'll be take over taken over by
the council um in due course once they
meet the required standard um that work
is due to commence in the third of
January um in the new year and hopefully
that will address that point it was to
be done last year but with Co issues and
getting contractors both ourselves and
the district council tried to get
contractors on board and it just wasn't
possible at the time of year it was
required so I'd like to give you that
assurance that the work is going to be
done now Pimon will be paying for it and
uh the council will be taking on that
area in Phase
One in terms of the other issue raised
about working in Sundays I've not heard
anything about work taking place in
Sundays from your enforcement team that
is something thing that is outside the
REM of of the decision today but I take
it on board and we will make sure that
uh all our workers are brought up to
speed with the approved construction
management plan to ensure that they
stick to the requirements within that
plan in terms of the PV panels the
number that's specified in your report
for six is based on the original
sustainability envir statement that was
submitted with the application as
Vincent Pierce has explained we have now
uh agreed with the council we will
provide the 19% reduction in carbon um
which is required in the emerging local
plan and that means that the
photovoltaic panels will be increased in
number I believe that will now be
approximately 35 to 40 of the units will
now uh incorporate PV
panels and that is there is a condition
I think that Mr Pierce has put in the
permission to require further details
about how that 19% will be achieved so
so we'll submit the the details in due
course to discharge that uh is there any
reason why you mean just because you've
got to the 19% is there another other
reason why you not installing
more just because you want you know you
get to 19% and that's I it I think uh
well we're going over and above the
existing policy of 10% so we're we're
making a a fair and reasonable offer I
think by increasing it to the local plan
which we know and have heard is not
adopted yet so
I think that's the offer we're making we
hope it'll be acceptable to
members thank you chair morning Stuart I
just want to ask a question around the
early years I know it's to do with the
County Council but I noticed on the plan
that the early Year's parking was going
to be incorporated
into sort of the estate isn't it um I
have no idea how many places the early
years are going to attract but do you
think that is adequate parking for when
perhaps 20 30 mothers and staff are
going to be parking in the adjacent
street is that
adequate okay we don't have the parking
details yet what normally happens with
the early year facilities or any land
that's taken on by the County Council is
that they would do a feasibility study
and then that would establish how many
parking spaces are required and that's
also governed by the suff County Council
um adopted parking standards as well so
I'm confident there's enough room there
to provide the parking that's required
as your officers have explained earli
it's a highly sustainable location here
with connections for cycles and buses
bus provision coming into the site as
part of the 106 obligations on us uh and
hope that in 600 houses you know it
might even generate a need for people
for local employ employment so they
could walk to um the facility as well
but I'm confident we could provide the
necessary parking that's that would be
required thank you thank you
chair thank you Mr chairman I've been
having a look through the the papers Etc
um and there's been quite a lot of
mention about brick walls to break up
the site um we saw on one of the slides
this has got to be a brick wall um what
measures are you putting in place to
encourage the the wildlife effectively
across what was effectively a piece of
open Countryside and is now going to be
enclosed in with properties Etc are you
going to have Hedgehog corridors through
uh fences or walls uh and certainly I
know that just to the town side of that
site there are a lot of active badges uh
that come into people's Gardens Etc uh
so I know i' site further just a bit
further down um dukee Street I think it
was that we had a a proposal and they
had to put in a a badger Corridor
effectively to allow the Badgers to move
from place to place so what proposals
are you putting in to help uh the ground
seeking uh uh parts of our Wildlife
rather than Swift boxes and things like
that where people can fly to
them I mean as part of the submission
there was a suite of ecology reports um
submitted with the application which
have mitigation measures within them so
we'll certainly be adhering to them I
don't remember um if there's anything to
do with Badgers in there but as part of
the proposals obviously there's a lot of
open space here we've got the Wetland
areas around the basins um which will be
planted out as well as as Mr Pierce has
alluded to earlier and we've got a set
of landscape drawings which will also be
submitted for uh the details to be
discharged as well which we can address
these things as well so very keen on
ecology as a matter of course now we
incorporate uh fence panels with
Hedgehog holes in them and we're doing
that in all of our sites now so yes a
range of measures in planting to
increase the amount of
biodiversity U on the site and also the
mitigation measures that we've provided
for offsite through the section one
contributions for H mitigation as
well you have a question
uh thank you Mr chairman I've got two um
just following on from the walls um will
they be long to the householder or will
they be gifted to the householder
because the last one we want is brick
walls built 10 years down the road they
fallen down and nobody's taken
responsibility to replace them that's
the first one and the second one which
you be fair aware of Stewart um on some
of your other pron sites in great
cornard you
created awful um frontages where the
boundary at the front of the property
and then to the edge of the curbstone of
the road it was a surface area which was
Green Grass and people used to park and
churn them up can I be assured they are
foot paaths um and not areas that can be
chewed up uh in front of them uh because
they become unsightly we've had them
even glemsford hav we Mr
chairman right thank you but Stuart
knows exactly what I'm on about yeah
thank you councelor beer in terms of the
walls they will be conveyed uh if
they're part of the curtilage to the
homeowner so they'll be responsible for
the ongoing maintenance of the walls any
walls which would have form within a
public area would have be looked after
maintained by the Manco I don't believe
there's any in these situations but
certainly residential Pro to take them
on the service trips I know exactly what
you're talking about I don't believe and
Gary might be able to confirm this that
we have any grass areas of service
strips within this
development the only um vergence you've
got is long the main infrastructure Ro
but divides the residential and the
employment and they're two met verges
but are actually also acting as spiles
as part of the S
strategy obviously they'll still have
full height curbs with um drop curves to
low drain that replaces a gully trying
trying not to be too technical but it
replaces a gully to get the water into
the S but in the residential air all the
road categories being shared surface
minor major access roads so they're
buttered by over a foot path or a
surfaced maintenance strip of a meter
wide just no any grass version or
anything will actually be someone's
front garden not high
rate any more questions for the agent
council
department yep thank you sh morning
Stuart um I'm just um coming out of left
field a little bit but um members quite
rightly in these um larger development
applications um concentrate on EV
charging points and PV panels and and
the like which offer very good public
benefits um I'm I'm conscious that we're
talking 273 dwellings here in total um
so I'm just wondering if P Simmons would
consider um a defibrillator um in in
addition to um the the other public
benefits that it it's it's a tiny
relative cost but with a substantial
public benefit um in my own home Village
of of Newton we've got Circa 300
premises at the moment we've got two
defibrillators and a proposal to add a
further three um so uh 273 dwellings
here they need to be within uh 4 minutes
of uh of of defibrillator is that
something that P Simmons would consider
please yeah I'm consci ious that that
this has come up at other committees
that we've not been involved in we've
already made an offer because we we
monitor some of the the committee
meetings as well we have a defibrillator
in all our sites and we'd be quite happy
to leave that behind as the construction
ends and we'll leave it on site and a
position to be agreed with the Town
Council or whoever we're quite happy to
do that I know it falls outside the plan
and reement but happy to accept an
informative to that effect and provide
that any more questions for the
agent any more questions for the officer
Council BBY did you have a question that
hasn't been answered yet or or yes I do
have a question that's not been answered
yet and you're going to direct it to who
well I was going to direct it to the
officer since it's his report okay
that's all right um You state that it's
not appropriate to consider Class E for
the employment site but when we look at
Classy there's a whole host
of what i' call fairly gentle employment
uh things like uh cres Nursery Indoor
Sport Financial
Services all of those kind of things
which would seem far more preferable to
having what you seem to want to
encourage which is class
B8 distribution and
storage which we seem to get everywhere
and they're
just pretty obnoxious buildings that uh
Dominate and encourage lots of traffic
traffic why on Earth would you prefer B8
to
e our principle concern is that e also
includes
retail and if we are looking to follow
the Town Center first principle what we
wouldn't want is retail on this site to
compete with what we have in the town
cent in Hadley and other retail
locations now you may say well I've
taken a a hammer to cracken n
what about all the other uses that may
be acceptable what we're what we're
saying is we're sticking to the
original understanding of business uses
that doesn't stop somebody coming
forward and saying well actually we have
a number of um we have demand for some
of the units that would fall into class
E but that would have to be an
application and we consider the merits
of
that but principally that is there to
prevent retail from springing up
directly to compete with the High
Street I didn't think it was our role as
a council to prevent
competition correct but it is our role
to ensure that designated retail centers
remain viable and vital so what we're
doing is ensuring that with the Town
Center first approach that we do as much
as we can to protect and
reinforce the value of Our Town Center
in terms of that's the most sustainable
location that's where people tend to to
head and in a in an economy ravaged by
coid the last thing we want to do is
undermine the Town Center further by
potentially having other users on other
sites for the agent first no was back
the op can I thank the agent very
much and we'll move on more questions
for the
officer
okay just just a quick one on that last
point on U on
retail uh bearing in mind that there is
a bearing in mind that there is a
shop uh
within 400 yards of the start of Lady
Lane and the entrance to this site to
the top phase one of this site um
does supporting the Town Center seem a
little bit uh of a rather frail argument
considering that the distance between
the town center and this development and
the number of people that are going to
be living there um considering there is
a shop just a little bit further down
the High Street because then it becomes
a matter of down lady Lane sorry which
then becomes a commercial matter uh and
just as a a slight as side I do find it
rather strange when uh a development in
my Village uh that argument didn't come
up at all when uh it was talking about a
development with a shop on it that would
effectively take business away from the
Village
Center done
now I think my answer would have to be
it's a question of
scale what we have is a
designated uh retail
Center the Hadley
is a town center serving The Villages
around as well it's strategically
important as a retail Center and what
we're looking at here is potentially 5.5
hectares of land you imagine what might
happen if that all happened to be 5.5
hectares of retail space what we're
suggesting is that we just need that
degree of control to ensure that we
don't decimate the Town Center it
doesn't stop us looking at um modest or
appropriate scales of development but it
ensures we have that remat because if
it's Class E anything in class E is
acceptable and where we're talking about
retail it is such a sensitive sector
that we do feel we need that control and
all your retail policies are predicated
on having a cluster of retail centers
within the district as soon as you
undermine that principle we're back to
out of town retailing all over the place
and the issues that that brings in terms
of the structure of the retail industry
which is is already under I mean it's
undergoing a seismic change as we speak
but at the moment our policies are
predicated on
protecting strategic Town centers and at
the top of the settlement hierarchy
obviously Hadley sits at the top of
that
structure com thank you chairman yes I
think my perspective on this is as Mr
Pierce says we've got a principle which
is important
if an application comes forward for a
specific user in a specific set of
circumstances um arguably as a as a
separate full application on this land
we'll look at it on its merits but I
think at this stage with such a large
allocation uh of land within the scheme
the important point is to uh keep that
decision for its specific merits because
uh Class E is a very Broad and most
commentators on planning will will will
tell you class class E is a
a a a provision of very significant
consequence so we do continue to
recommend that you keep this control and
it isn't exclusion it is simply keeping
that
control thank you Council
jamson on that same topic then do we
have to offer warehouses I mean that's
just going to encourage big glor come
down through
ham um potentially through um other
Villages and it's
just it's going to cause all sorts of
problems in that respect I mean do we
have to offer that as
well our employment strategy and
policies are predicated on supporting B1
B8 uses that is our
policy right well we'll move on
um the
site has two Ward members one's not very
well and the other one has sent his
apologies but he's provided us with a
statement that the government's officer
will now
read thank you
chair I regret that I am unable
apologies this is from councelor MC
Fraser I regret that I am unable to
attend today's committee and speak on
behalf of Hadley South W with respect to
planning applications dc1
95419 please pass on my apologies to the
committee in my email of 7th of March
2021 I stated that I had no objections
to this application as there was no
legal reason to do so this Remains the
case and for the following reasons I
support the officer recommendation to
Grant permission for this application
and would like to highlight the
following points for my reasoning one
there appears to be no legal reason to
object nor any critical obstacles
identified for this development to
proceed as an adopted development plan
this application fulfills the
requirements of the 20 2014 core
strategies Hadley CS
six two many of the objection comments
from Hadley residents and the Town
Council have been answered by planning
officers and addressed by the applicant
also the applicant has been quick to
correct issues raised by residents with
respect to the phase 1B adjacent
development three I'm satisfied with the
schedule of s106 payments which includes
more than2 million for education
$7,300 for health contribution
8,250 for the town sporting facilities
and a surprise in £50,000 highways
commitment specifically for Benton
Street
improvements four I would have preferred
to have seen more engineering applied to
Tower Mill Lane seeing it metal and
illuminated along its entire length
however I accept that the access to
George Street from the development is
mostly along a bridal way over private
land the measures considered for
installation both by suffk and per Simon
are adequate I'm grateful to Stuart
mcadam's offer for the developer to
carry out maintenance to this path where
they can it would be be useful and
appreciated if the councils would
continue with this P maintenance after
the development is
completed five I am pleased with the
effort and dialogue between the planning
officers and piman homes and I would
like to commend Vincent Pierce for his
work on this project and for bringing
this report to the committee Pimon homes
has considered concerns and suggestions
from Hadley residents and bab officers
and counselors including the Village
Green area green credentials evv
charging points and reducing the CO2
levels on the development your sincer
councel mcf Fraser thank you chair thank
you okay we'll open the item for debate
coun be you're
Keen kick off well Mr chairman I'm clean
because I've just heard the response
from the local member and he fully
supports this um we've had a full report
that we'd expect from Mr Pierce uh
excellent um uh outline and all the
details we've had questions to him we
spoke to the applicants I'm more than
happy at this stage Mr chairman to
recommend that we accept the officer's
recommendation for approval thank you do
you have a second councilor bar your
second yeah I'm very happy to second I
think we've had a very full um
thorough uh presentation as over from
Vince so um yeah happy to second that
and I don't really need you to speak any
thank
you does anyone else what to comment c
m close
c c not MCG you keep doing it it's okay
um I do apologize this has only just
occurred to me but it was brought up in
another member's comment and it was
regarding Street lighting and and dark
skies because we have got a boundary
issue here and I just wondered if
anybody could comment on what the street
lighting arrangements for the site uh
particularly the uh domestic the housing
site might
be that would be a a matter for suff
County Council under the section 38
agreements and what they always say is
that they don't necessarily require
Estates to be lit but what they are
required to do is if it connects with an
estate or or public hybrid that is
already lit they have to then ensure
that the next bit is is lit so because
we have uh the bridal way that can in a
sense bisects this site with the 1B I'm
not sure whether or not Street lighting
is required but what we can do is have a
discussion outside of this meeting and
outside of the um the applications with
our County colleagues to determine
whether or not they feel that street
lighting is necessary if not I think
we'd all prefer that that sort of
Illumination was kept to a minimum or or
not at all but it's outside of the remit
um bmen don't have control of that we
don't as the planning Authority did are
our County colleagues with your
permission chair may I just add one
point um and it's it's it's something
that we did in Long mou and it's
something we've done on other sites and
I I'm hoping I'm going to Spring this on
Stuart but where there has been a little
bit of tension perhaps on earlier phases
it will be interesting to see whether
Pimon would agree to a dialogue with the
ward members and Town Council perhaps on
a six monthly
basis in order that were such issues to
arise again there would be an immediate
Avenue for those to be explored Direct
locally with the um the developer and in
a sense that hopefully we'll cut out my
colleague at Simon and the enforcement
team and is probably a much more
amicable way to try and resolve issues
locally
comments councelor Osborne you haven't
had a go for a
while thank you Stephen uh yeah thank
you Mr chairman I'd just just like to
say that I'm in agreement with councilor
beer and councelor Barrett for this for
this application uh to be approved and I
would just like to site the the obvious
perhaps that most of the uh well all of
the uh dots and all of the t's have been
crossed very very well by uh by the
officer um Mr Pierce and uh I'd just
like to say how good the presentation
was I I thought it was very well covered
thank you Mr chairman
thank you H Jameson you wanted to come
in uh yeah just um I'm disappointed
again to see that we're got a developer
installing gas boilers and only a
fraction of the PV panels they could and
I know they're going to the 19% of the
joint local plan which um is what they
need to do and it's show probably
showing more weakness of our joint
potential joint merging joint local plan
and actually had little n teams what
what companies little companies need to
do to reach that
19% rather than I mean assumingly doing
going above what they need to do but um
yeah again it's not a lot
really
comments Cas be yes Mr chairman I think
that's a little bit unfair that last
statement uh I think they have gone
further they've gone from 10 to 19% and
I think we have to remember that
whatever demands we put on these
developers they're not um going to be
terribly out of pocket this will be
reflected on the process of these and we
have to remember that people still need
homes whether they're affordable whether
they can um actually um afford to buy
one outright it it's all costly so I I I
do think that yes we're right to try and
get as many green initiatives underway
and going and I I command my um
colleague because he does challenge this
all the time but I think we should also
recognize when a developer has gone
above what they need to do and yes we'd
like more of course we would but that
comes at a cost and I I certainly think
that you're you're doing well and if you
can pick up all the other points that
have been highlighted today um and work
with the local member and the Town
Council that's got to be a step in the
right direction and I I do commend that
we go out and put this to the vote Mr
chairman thank you
thank councelor Jameson for his comment
as
well councelor
McCraw gotcha thank you chair um I've
just been looking at this and I think
there's one thing I I will say that
attracted me actually is the fact that
uh the restriction on uh types B1 B2 and
B8 from personal experience in retail I
can assure you that uh uh shops retail
uses and bclass uses do not mix well and
particularly the idea of a nursery next
to a warehouse or a um uh I mean that's
a good example of of an e type use that
would would not be appropriate next to a
distribution center so I think that's an
entirely reasonable Point um I shall be
voting in favor of the of the
proposal councelor buby you just your
disagree on that I mean the thing that's
wrong with it is having the Distribution
Center there not having the the nursery
there's a there's a employment site in
neita Market where there's a a nursery
right next door to other employment
sites and it works very well that's
beside the point the the issue I have is
that us recommending that B8 should be
the employment uh type of choice for
this District I think that's crazy but
that's something we need to look at in
the future one of the things I um I was
kind of disappointed to but it still
could be salvaged is the £93,000 I think
it was for the sports provision and
there was some thought about it going to
the Hadley Rugby Club I would have
thought it would have been uh better
used as a Mugger up in that particular
area that doesn't seem to be any
provision for a for sports facilities up
there and a Mugger which would cater for
tennis football basketball netball
hockey would be uh an alternative and
not much more than the 93,000 so I think
that ought to be
considered um I was kind of disappointed
really that that we didn't have a site
visit for this um given that we'd got
the phase one just completed we could
have had good uh example of what we
could expect on phase two and it is
quite a complicated site in terms of the
access which isn't perfect by any
stretch of the
imagination chairman if I can just just
pick up on the section 106 point that
you raised there Council Busby um there
have been fairly lengthy conversations
with uh cpor manager for public realm
and uh the assistant uh director for
this uh service in relation to the
matter of the Rugby Club and that
question of what it's appropriate to
fund and secure so I mean we're
comfortable that um what we get here as
a contribution is is uh directing to an
appropriate purpose um and to that
extent I mean we recommend what we
recommend in the papers um uh uh can I
pick up on a couple of other points just
while I have the uh have the microphone
CH just for clarity um the proposal and
second of the motion are presely aware
that page 13 of the table papers there
are three additional conditions which
are uh recommended in there uh in
relation to the development and in
relation to the uh defibrillator point
that uh councelor Parker mentioned uh I
recall that this last came up in
relation to a blor homes development in
long mford and we uh we didn't impose a
condition but we did add an informative
note to expect the defibrillator to be
provided because that would be
supportive of our um well-being strategy
and uh I'll look at the applicant's
agent to uh confirm that's that's a way
of of dealing with these things chairman
which we how we'd approach it thank
you you yeah thank you Mr I just uh go
back to uh Mr Pierce's uh last comment
about the um area of
um uh consultation with with the ward
members and also parishes uh I can say
that it does work and I'd like to see
that done it's worked with the CH and
I'm afraid I'll use the word of the
other
developers who probably not with uh with
you at the moment but uh for Simmons uh
but uh it does work they still are doing
consultations as that project goes
forward so uh yes I absolutely agree
with Mr Pierce on that one I would like
to see that happen thank you thank thank
you Mr
chairman no more then I'll ask the chief
planning officer to read out the
proposal for us um in terms you
forgotten it's one of your duties
I chairman I think there are various
duties you might say I mean the
recommendation is within uh your
papers uh and section 106 uh elements
are all uh detailed in advance of the
recommendation but effectively your
recommendation starts on page 103 but as
I say there's obviously the table papers
page 13 uh and we've suggested the
inclusion of an informative note as well
to deal with defibrillator point and I
think that sweeps it up
chair your second happy with that thank
you okay I'll ask the government officer
now to carry out the
vote
I'm just going to add in about the
informative
okay okay members that vote is
now in progress in your
app
councel Hinson are you okay to vote or
do I need to take your vote manually
verbally
thank
you thank you so chair that's nine votes
for and two against thank you very much
that is passed thank you I suggest we
have a five minute break to to allow the
officers to wipe down no offense to
gentlemen but we
we're
welcome back
everyone we now have a planning
application for parsonage Lan
Charlesworth and the officer is
Elizabeth flood ask her to introduce the
subject to the
committee if I may sorry excuse me my
colleague excuse me and you Mr chairman
just councelor um Jameson the ward
member just asked my advice about the
practicalities and for this item I he he
won't be part given the current
circumstances we won't move him to
anywhere else in the room but he'll stay
where he is he you'll invite him to
speak as the ward member at the right
moment and then he won't otherwise
participate in the vote or discussion
thank
you please continue
okay so this is um a planning
application for the erection of one and
our one and a half story dwelling um
you'll note that within the tabled
papers is a copy of the previous appeal
decision and also a statement from the
parish uh chairman uh the parish
meetings uh chairman uh which you should
have received this
morning
so this is the site here this is
parsonage Barn in this location here and
this is uh whistle craft Cottage and
this is passeng lane and then just at
the top here you can see the main road
through
galsworth again site location PL this is
the site um with the access that this is
the access to parsonage barn and then
this is whistle coft Cottage here
again this shows the constraints map so
you'll see that um whistle craft Cottage
and the the uh Cottage a little bit
further up the lane are both grade two
listed uh this is the conservation area
for chelsworth and this is the builtup
area boundary so the site is outside of
uh the conservation area and outside of
the builtup area
boundary
and this shows
um the application and also um the
position of the
extent um permission here slightly
further back and also it shows what has
been um given what permission has been
granted at parsonage Barn so that's to
be developed into a five-bedroom
dwelling
here however this is the block plan
again you can see the extant permission
and this was also at the location for
the um the application that was
refused um so the the new dwelling uh
the proposal is slightly further forward
with the garage at the front again you
could see the extensions to passage Barn
that are currently being built and you
can see um The Cottage
there
again proposed layout you can see um two
trees are proposed to be removed these
here in brown uh and then the dwelling
would be in this location with the
garage cart Lodge
here um and there would be some more
additional Landscaping in this
location and at the
front these are the proposed elevations
so uh this front elevation and the rear
elevation uh you can see see it's one
and a half stories it would be fatch uh
with
weatherboard and then um and quite
traditional at the front at the front
and uh more modern at the back with some
glassed areas and some glazing and a
large balcony at this point
here again these are the side elevations
so you can see uh the single story
elements to it these would be
pantiles um this is the floor plan so
it's a free bedroom dwelling so these
are the living areas uh bedroom
here and then at the top you'd have the
the two two more bedrooms and then this
is the large sort of balcony roof
Terrace
area right roof PL you can see the fatch
and the
tiles again these are the garage cart
Lodge traditional
design okay so this is the street scene
so this is parage barn with its
extensions and garage this this would be
the new
dwelling and then this is the uh whistle
Croft Cottage
here can see
that again this is um a perspective
street view from whistle cof Cottage so
you can see it
here um then you can see the dwelling
and then you can see parsonage Barn at
the
end again this is showing its front
perspective you can just see probably
that it's just set back set in To The
Ground by about 45 cm so it is would be
dug in a little
bit and so this is a view from parage
Lane again this is the rear can see the
sort of balcony roof
Terrace so these are the photographs so
this is the photograph of the site these
two trees would be
removed to be for the for the dwelling
to be put in there again this is sort of
the front of the
site see
here then this is looking from the site
towards parsonage Barn so you can see
that the extensions at parsonage barns
are being undertaken at the
moment uh this is uh whistle craft
Cottage and then this shows this is the
corner of the site and you can just see
whistle cof Cottage at the end there
it's about 55 MERS between the two
properties again you can just see there
that's cage
there again this is looking from whistle
coft Cottage towards the site which is
just about you can just see the car
there that's where it is so this is the
the view from the
lane okay so this application the
history is quite significant um so I've
just put up some of the key uh inspector
comments this was from the twostory or
one and a half story dwelling which was
refused and held up in
appeal um so you can see it was
regarding the height and size um and the
impact on the listed
building um and then there was moderate
weight to the public
benefits so this is just to give you a
bit of comparison so this was what was
refused this was the one and a half
story
dwelling and uh so that was the front
and the rear and the sides and I've just
put it next next to the what's proposed
now now I should say that these have not
scaled so this is just indicative of the
differences um and they would be on
different sites so the proposed dwelling
now would be forward of what was
previously approved and previously
refused sorry again so this is the rear
uh compared with the rear
here again these show the S uh the side
elevation so you can see that um The
Proposal now has um um a lot more single
story elements so these are the single
story um elements and then this one and
a half Story
part okay um this is the floor the floor
pans so it was a five bedroom dwelling
that was
refused and then this was what was has
has been approved so this is the extent
permission as you can see it's a really
low level low impact
dwelling uh
that's the rear and the
front and it was for this is the floor
area of the extent permission so it's a
free free bedroom
dwelling and as set out in your report
uh it's considered that the The Proposal
would cause a low level of um less than
significant harm to the neighborhood
listed building and to the character of
the conservation area and that that harm
is not outweighed by the public benefits
um because there is an extent permission
so uh there is the benefits of of the
single dwelling have already be could be
provided by the extent permission thank
you thank you Elizabeth any questions
for the officer
please councelor
Parker yeah thank you chair and and
forgive me because I'm I'm I'm quite
sure this is in here but um the EXT St
permission um was was that granted to
the applicant of this
permission I don't believe
so you were going to
ask okay any other questions to the
officer no
okay um we were due to have a parish
meeting representative but they have
been taken ill and they have sent us um
a note and I hope you've all been able
to read
it thank you unfort won't be able to ask
him any
questions but as there's no objector we
have a supporter to speak so perhaps we
can ask him Peter ker would you please
speak for three
minutes good
morning my name is Peter Kar I am a
retired chartered surveyor with a
professional lifetime of advis ing on
Heritage Property many in the bber area
I have lived in parsonage lane
chelsworth for 31 years the same Lane as
the applicant's building plot as you are
aware a planning permission has already
been granted on the site so the
principle of development is
Undisputed the existing permission is
for a building favored by V's planning
officers but by no one
else turning to David and bessel's
application the vernacular design
enables it to assimilate into its
setting the impact is certainly less
than a previous refused
permission examining the planning
officer's report on the application in
front of you the site is said to be
within the setting of the grade two
listed whistle craft
Cottage even though that building is 55
M
distant whistle craft is described as a
single story building with
attics that was the case once but
unfortunately what started out as a to
up two down thatched Cottage has over
recent years been totally transformed by
various different
extensions into a very large house whose
historic Origins have been virtually
completely
subsumed to the east of the application
site is parage bar
itself this formerly modest Barn is
stated by the Heritage officer as a
non-designated Heritage asset and was
the subject of a permitted development
approval however the Heritage asset has
been almost completely obliterated by
two massive extensions having recently
been given planning permission and now
under
construction the Heritage officer did
not feel the need to object at the time
of the
application so much for protecting our
heritage assets that the Heritage
department has been acquiescent in the
effective obliteration of these two
assets is
unforgivable that they now want to
intervene on this building plot is a sad
joke the bessels application site is
outside but close to the boundary of
chelsworth Conservation Area and the
second area of concern the planning
officer is stated to be the impact this
application design would have it is
clear to me and many others that the
existing modernistic legol light
permission would have a far greater
impact it would stick out like a sore
thumb in conclusion I would ask you to
consider do you want the existing
approval
built which even to be kind has the
appearance of an electricity substation
or do you want a sympathetically
designed home supported by every single
resident in parsonage Lane thank
[Applause]
you the
Border councelor
Parker uh yes just just thank you Mr ker
just with regards to your very last
Point how many residents are there in
bage
Lane uh two three
five
seven
people thank you Mr chairman um could I
just ask you um the plan permission that
you have for the ex um for the new
dwelling I mean I've looked at it it
looks ugly um I don't like that at all I
don't have a problem with new houses in
the countryside and even being larger um
and I I do take your point of the um the
Heritage not getting involved in the
other one but getting involved here um
so I do have some sympathy with you but
my question to you is really that first
the the plans that you've got for
approval uh were they what your
applicant
needed would I be better place to ask to
answer that question
well um GE together aren't you well I'm
the I'm the applicant oh you're the oh
sorry sorry yes yes I beg your pardon on
that any questions for the
supporter no thank you then I'll ask the
the applicant Mr David Bessel to speak
to us for three
minutes it's extremely important to Jude
and I to build something that fits in
with chelworth the approved design has
generated a great deal of hostility from
Neighbors on both sides the chairman of
the village meeting who's been given a
mandate to object and every one of the
villages we have spoken to
directly we changed our original
proposal after a pre-application meeting
from an oak framed building because the
planning officer said that if a design
looked more like a barn it would stand a
better chance the current proposal
follows this advice we've consulted with
both Neighbors about how to lessen any
impact on them and have reduced the
design substantially in size by around
45 square meters and brought it
significantly for W in the plot in line
with the street
scene from the new position there is a
very limited direct sight line to
whistlecopter on the setting of whistle
craft Cottage and most of our proposal
is Now hidden from whistle craft by its
own most easterly
extension whistle craft is not as
described in the Heritage officer report
the core is a 17th century Cottage but
there have been five extensions and
additions over the years which have
altered its character
substantially the preference for Mass
overdesign I.E ultramodern versus
blending in goes against every opinion
in chelsworth and is contrary to the
view of our very experienced Heritage
con
consultant the ministry of housing
communities and local government in the
National design guide says that
well-designed new development is
integrated into its wider surroundings
which helps Foster a sense of belonging
and Co and Community cohesion and welld
designed places may include adopting
typical building forms and drawing upon
the architectural precedents that are
prevalent lastly there is also planning
precedence continuity consistency and
fairness to consider first the plans of
parsonage barn immediately adjacent have
been improved despite a substantial
increase in overall footprint to the
original secondly there's a very
substantial construction only a mile
away in the street in monili with five
listed buildings within a few meters of
it and inside the conservation area not
outside nothing we are proposing is
anything more than those applications
already granted and you could argue
substantially less we are hoping to be
treated with the same
consideration we're aiming to achieve a
building that will add to the character
and vernacular of Charlesworth not
detract from it something that not only
Jude and I but the village can be proud
of for the next century and beyond as it
weathers down to be part of that street
scene thank you thank
you councelor bar you have a
question um yes um I I pick up on your
point about pre-application advice yes
um so you obviously consulted with the
planning department we did and they gave
you the advice that a bar would be
suitable they gave us very little advice
throughout the um the preapp meeting um
very little positive advice they didn't
really work with us to to say well if
you did this uh you could we could work
there was no working there it was a
passing comment by the planning officer
uh when she looked at and and we had
made that appeal we said we said well
can you tell us what we can do to
achieve something that would work here
and they said well first off they said
uh well we're not going to design your
house for you which we found slightly um
unhelpful but secondly they said well um
if it looked more like a a bar then uh
you would stand a better chance and that
was about the sum total of our positive
Eng so did you ever ever had written um
representation from the planning
department no so had you paid for any
preapplication advice you had paid for
it yes absolutely yeah and you had no oh
we got we got um a report back of the
meeting that we had held yes but there
was nothing positive in there okay thank
you question couldn't be answer by the
supporter yes thank you it was um the
the plan application that's in existence
is for very low um uh single um sort of
height dwelling is that correct it's for
this it's what's known as a low impact
dwelling soal yes well that looks very
ugly to the
um it's a horrendous building in in my
opinion well I'm surprised you went
along with it but I'm I'm disappointed
to hear right the uh the the lack of
support and advice you got from officers
because yes we have encouraged them
certainly in the past to go out of their
way not design your house I do agree
there with you um but uh to give you
ideas of what might be acceptable what
definitely wouldn't be acceptable and um
that to me
would have been helpful I'm I'm
disappointed to hear you didn't get that
thank well I'd rather hear my answer
from the applicant on what I said first
thank you we were very disappointed as
well actually um we expected to go in
with a positive and proactive um
attitude to try and get a solution um
that would suit all parties including
those most importantly for us those
people of chelsworth who are going to
have to live with this building and we
did didn't um we didn't just buy this uh
plot with a building on it we looked at
and we waited um and investigated the
precence of parage Lane itself um
because um and we didn't buy it until
our red line was whether or not the
application that was going through at
the time for the barn next door passage
Barn next door with the extensions um
either side whether that was approved
and if that was approved at such a scale
another 30% larger than than our
suggestion um then we decided that that
um at that point the precedent has been
set so we thought that if we put in um
something that was a third smaller uh
than that on and as a replacement for
this what we believe and still believe
is an extremely ugly uh building um that
it would be looked upon favorably
because the barn next door had been
passed that that was why we bought the
land there there was no arrogance to
think that that we'll just do it and
change the plant that wasn't what we
were trying to
do
uh chairman I hesitate before saying too
much here there are differences of
opinion about what what happened at the
preat meeting and about what was written
but written advice was given uh and I
believe from what I've seen and heard
that uh we Endeavor to give uh
constructive advice accepting this is a
site with high risk associated with it
given that there is a previous appeal
that's in uh your papers you can judge
that for yourself we will doubtless end
up discussing this further as need be um
I think it's fair to say it is not the
role of the Heritage team to design uh
solutions for applicants uh and uh we
therefore Endeavor to work within a
narrow brief to try and provide
constructive advice but in the end an
applicant must make their own judgment
and I think uh there are differing
opinions about the extent of that advice
and what use it was for the applicant
but nonetheless advice was given and it
was given in writing as I understand
it m m thank you very much morning Mr
Bessel um just a really to clear up one
thing is the extant permission on the
same piece of land that this application
is for or is it in the further back
position of the permission that was
refused on appeal the exan permission is
uh in the middle of the
plot um uh which is within a flood zone
flood zone 2 to start off with um but
also increased is the sight line to
whistle craft we have moved our design
forward to take it out of the flood R
zone risk into flood zone risk one and
uh and also to reduce those sight loans
so we've we've moved it Forward by the
um by the the size of a house actually
so forward in the plot so just to recap
from the original permission that was
refused upon appeal which was towards
the back of the site the extent
permission moves further forward no the
extand permission was on the same
footprint as the refused permission um
and they just basically chopped the top
off it right so yours is completely
further forward so it's not on the same
position piece of land or exactly the
same plot of land as as the extand
commission that's all I needed to know
thank
you Council Parker you were next and
then Council Owen thank you chair um
good morning Mr Bessel um just picked up
one within your presentation you
mentioned that um uh the proposed
application is nowhere near the mass of
the refused permission um so obviously
we we we saw a diagram of of of the two
and appreciate I said that they weren't
scaled but they looked fairly similar to
me um and you say they're nowhere near
the mass yeah can you clarify what we um
tried to do very much so was we took
into account whistle ccraft this all
hinges around whistle craft let's face
it and the and the influence that we
have on it um and so we needed to have
bedrooms uh that of a decent size but we
wanted to the whole reason for pulling
it so far forward and to put an
elevation at the front was to get that
height at the front where you couldn't
see it and and the extension to the east
of whistle Craft um of on the cottage
itself blocks the sight line so there
was no view from that one and a half
story and therefore if we put the a
single story at the back we could very
much minimize any influence on whistle
craft because it's only a single story
at the back okay it has a gabled roof
and not a flat grass roof but it's still
a single story so um with even moderate
growth at the sides of the plot it would
very much limit that sight line from
whistle
craft and that's what I meant about um
the mass is reduced it's that that back
area thank you um I was just having a
look at the design and the um layout
you've got a um a large balcony does
that affect anyone at all no right so um
this large balcony was brought up a
couple of times actually
it's there are rooms below it and so
actually it would be a flat roof all
we've done really is put a a balcony
around it um so that occasionally we
might go up on and look at the sun go
down with a glass of wine so it's not
going to be used it's just to make use
of a flat roof rather than just having a
flat roof um and it is slightly below
the level of the Gable um and um it is
far enough forward so that when you look
east or west from there towards whistle
craft or to passage Barn you can't see
it and passage Barn is actually end on
in it slight curve to where we are so
that it's not overlooking that at all so
no it it really doesn't impact on anyone
and in fact the fenestration uh report
from some of the documents talks about
the fenestration on our design on on the
east and west sides of it
um doesn't impact on either parage barn
or um on or whistle ccraft and this is
exactly the same thing it's less than
the fenestration on on the sides of the
building thank you I will now ask
Council Jameson as the ward member to
address the
committee thank you
chair um when I was U first made aware
of the original application there was a
lot of um opposition amongst the
Village um when that application came
forward um in the area the area next to
whistle craft was open Countryside and
whistle craft was at the the end of the
lane that application which as I say was
opposed by by most or everyone a lot of
the village was submitted for a large
property and was correctly dismissed due
to its overall size and um and location
both by Baba and on
appeal as stated by the inspector it was
two stories and with two story
Gables um and it was located further
down the field than this application and
was oppressive and dominant and would
have overshadowed whistle
Craft um this was at a time before the
pass Spade pass this parage Barn
application had been
submitted the
um the subs application which was
submitted by the same developer for the
site was approved and um such it can be
argued that some harm has already been
agreed to whistle Craft um by
babber the harm as has been stated
previously by the um supporters and by
Mr
bezel um has been further compounded by
the construction of the parage or the
approval and the building of the passage
B application which is
about um five 00 M fur down the lane and
also outside the built up area
boundary um this property which names
the application is a large property of
three join buildings as has been stated
and effectively it will look like three
houses when completed yet deemed was
deemed to offer no harm to whistle
craft so we've agreed as a council that
the property can built in the field in
question we've also agreed that a much
bigger property can be built next door
and neither of these things were present
when the original application was dism
dismissed by the inspector on
appeal a lot has been made of the height
of the properties and that is much but
the original development was a much
bigger overall Mass although this one is
the same height it has
been the wings at at the back are single
story and is um been further improveed
been further reduced as M Mr Mrs bezel
will lower the ground level to move the
house and move the house closer to the
top of the field to ensure that the roof
line is in level with whistle
craft as well as ensuring that the roof
levels form a consistent line moving the
property forward will allow the proposed
property to be screamed from whle Craft
by trees and hedge
R the bezels have looked at the village
and are trying to build a property that
they love also one that fits in with a
historic setting Village setting of
talsworth and tillworth is arguably one
of the prettiest villages in the
district district is not the prettiest
and the vast majority of the dwellings
are old with many listed and the
residents are very conscious about this
and want to retain the essence of what
makes the really special and as such
they in this case they've been fully
inter po of this application over the um
single story application that has been
agreed um for this site that
application um may meet Heritage
criteria but it is um will not fit in
and it will stand out like a s thumb if
it's built it's a modern
contemporary looking
building and um as I say we not fitting
with the village and it was strongly
opposed uh I cannot see that the harm
caused by this building would be any
worse than the harm that has been agreed
in the previous applications both for
this site and for the Par Bar
application um a few few yards
down but it will fit in with a wider
setting of the historic village and I
would encourage members of the committee
to consider
approval thank you thank
you any questions for the ward
member than be uh thank you Mr chairman
just to be clear because you said quite
a lot near the end and that you approve
are you saying that you're in favor uh
or you give support to this I support
yeah yeah thank you very much I just
want to be clear on that thought that's
what you said such a lot I'm just like
to ask a quick question I'm just
interested in this word mass in terms of
uh a building I'm I'm I'm I I understand
the building's length I understand its
height I understand its width um and
mass has for me has to do with weight so
perhaps you could explain that term to
me please
as I meant it it just looked big because
of the nature of the way it was designed
it was it looked like a massive building
so it's Mass short for massive supp So
yeah thank
you councelor Baron I'm a bigger mass
than councelor
Jameson oh thank you for that
explanation thank you I was thought I
might have I might have to uh go to our
ComEd these to understand
but uh any more questions for the ward
member no then I'll thank you very much
and I will open it up for
debate um councelor
Parker you seem to get there first oh
sorry yeah I defer give way to your
young
for thank you thank you chair um
right chair so what I need to understand
is is to to what extent if any extent at
all um the dismissed appeal here is
material because there's there's been
lots of um comment about the extent
permission but it occurs to me that that
actually that it's not particularly
relevant the um the extent permission
because we've got a new application um
on the site of a uh of a refused
permission and indeed a dismissed appeal
um so it occurs to me that that that is
actually Rel so I I'd like to understand
a little bit more about that about that
refused appeal and and um what bearing
that has um on on this application
please thank you chairman I'll I'll
start shall I and we'll see where we get
to with this um um
so you're not deciding this application
but what you have is an inspector's
decision
which a reasonable decision maker should
have regard to and not ignore the
principles so that's the kind of
territory we
in um we also know that I think all of
the experts here agree that there are
two Heritage assets which are affected
first one is whistle ccraft Cottage and
so there is the extent of impact or harm
there and the second one is the adjacent
Conservation Area so we are in the
setting of Conservation Area rather than
the conservation are itself and those
two are Heritage assets for the purposes
of planning they dealt with and those
issues are dealt with in part in the
appeal
decision uh and the inspector in the
previous appeal looks at those and says
well this application gets us
to from my point of view this conclusion
on on on this proposal so in comparing
one with another one would sit and
calculate and make a judgment how much
one is comparable to another for the
purposes of
consistency so if you look at the appeal
decision in your table papers just so
we're clear about the issues never mind
the merits of the
scheme uh one can see that paragraphs 7
through to 10 deal
with those issues and the inspector
finds that those issues are harmed by
that
proposal now the complicating factor and
you have policy cs15 of your court
strategy back to planning
decision-making 101 um always follow the
development plan and L material
considerations indicate otherwise so
that's your statutory starting point and
you've got an inspector saying well this
is what I find about this application in
these circumstances and he applies cs15
which is a blanket policy in covers
amongst other things protecting
biodiversity protecting Heritage assets
and he comes to a conclusion on both the
setting of the conservation area and the
setting of whistle ccraft Cottage my
advice to any Committee in any any
similar situation is you've got to
engage with that appeal decision and try
and draw a consistent decision with it
unless you think the inspector is
absolutely mad for some other reason
that you can describe on the face of it
I think there's a bit of opinion in
this so then you're into this
application and I don't know how that
helps you with the previous appeal
decision but the inspector certainly
said in in that case we'd engaged the
question of the setting of the landscape
whistle craft Cottage and the
Conservation Area and he found the
application uh to be visible and
intrusive given its height and size uh
within an open rural setting of a listed
building I mean I'm paraphrasing hugely
I would rather that you actually refer
to this as you heard from Mr Bor there
are strong opinions running here and I
wouldn't wish to add to the opinion i'
rather get to the the kind of way the
decision is arrived at here uh and the
inspector makes VAR other comments about
the character of uh parage Lane in the
end if you look at the ation as you have
it your heritage advisor says there is
less than substantial harm to the
setting of whle craft Cottage and I
think he says it to the um there's harm
to the uh setting of the
conservation the applicants own advisor
because they have provided a Heritage
statement also concludes that there is
less than substantial harm at the low
end of the scale I think there's
agreement there's less than substantial
harm to the uh setting and character
conservation era and to the setting and
character of whistle craft Cottage I
don't think the heritage expert
particularly disagree although I
wouldn't want to quote it forba him I'm
going on memory here
um and that inevitably as a
decision-making body takes you to the
statutory duty to uh protect listed
buildings set out in the act and to the
policy Duty set out in the nppf where
the primary duty is to preserve uh and
Safeguard the significance of the
Heritage asset and then you have our old
friend of less than substantial harm can
only be outweighed by public benefit and
in the in the applicants Heritage
statement they describe three elements
of of benefit I I assume they mean
public benefit and they are new build
with high standard of thermal
performance and Ecco credentials
improvements to the existing landscape
of the site and Boundary treatments and
improvements to the biodiversity of the
site so if I can describe the landscape
for your decision I'm not entirely
convinced the Heritage experts disagree
there is
harm you your
decision is is is
obliged you've got an inspector saying
there's harm you got three other people
two other people saying there's harm uh
you you have to engage with that because
that's the statutory function and if you
are going to come to a decision you've
got to you should in all reasonless
follow the npf's weighing of lesson
substantial harm etc etc does that in
any way help you councelor Parker
find a clarification just while you're
still there is the uh this dwelling
that's been proposed I thought the
applicant said that it was um been moved
forward so it's not on the same site as
refused by the inspector that was my
understanding site perhaps if we look at
the actual site I think it has I think
there is some movement yes so I think
that's present
yeah
so the the plot is the same so the red
line site plan is the same but this here
in the pink dotted was what was was what
the position of the extant application
and the refused application so they were
in the same location and then you can
see where the proposed new um in is it's
just to the front it overlaps a tiny bit
but it's mainly to the front of that um
the extent and the refused
application
yes I think the pl Chief planning
officer came back to it in in in his
summary of the situation because once
again we come up against this position
of a lowlevel of less than substantial
harm and we all know that I mean how low
is low before it becomes insignificant
now clearly the planning inspector on
the original site found that that was
quite a high low
level if that makes sense um in terms of
the line of sight the positioning and
the and and the sort of impact of the
building I have to say that I mean
looking at this proposal in comparison
with that that was refused uh
by the inspector and also the extant
permission for the modern lowrise
building I have to say that this
application seems much more sympathetic
in style design context for the
environment context of the village
itself than either of those other two
permissions and I'd say that this is
likely to cause a very much lower level
than low so less than substantial I'd
say substantially less than substantial
um I know that's that's
cutting fines but then again I think
this is a point that we've come up
against before in planning on in similar
applications involving a Heritage asset
and the impact on Heritage assets it is
a very fine judgment I don't I don't
think that um I think the other thing is
when the planning inspector would have
looked at this as the member has pointed
out the
ex house the three volume house down the
road the three in one as it were um
hadn't been built and therefore the
impact this would have been the last
house if you like in a line well now
it's no longer the last house in the
line and all three properties are sort
of lined up in a street scene and that
seems to me to be quite a significant
difference from the position when the
planning inspector made his
decision
counc I I'm really going to labor this
point because it's important in in law
once you find harm you must find public
benefit and you must attach significance
you must attach great weight to the
preservation of the asset and that
whether I like it or not is the
landscape of this decision and once
you're into that question of harm you
have to find public benefit and and
those things you have to have presence
to do that so you know there is I'll
leave it there no I and I take I take
your point very well um in fact I'd say
I would do see some public benefit in
that that thatched approach rising up
from the ground in a traditional suffk
style bar seems to me to be a benefit in
comparison with what exists at the
moment or what could exist um and in the
context of everything else so I do
believe there is a benefit there um s
roofs modern s roofs aren't built that
often
than Baron of course what we are
overlooking is the fact that there's
already existing permission which is
there anyway so the public harm or the
the low level of harm would be
presumably implemented when the
permission was granted so that is there
the other thing that I'm pointing out
about the appeal process and the
inspector he's going back to our old
Chestnut of CS2 and cs1 he's actually
not really talking much about the um uh
the Heritage side more he's going on
about the conflict of cs11 and CS2 which
is one that we've often had in this and
if you look at his last his overall
paragraph that is basically what he's
saying it's in conflict with our hin and
our um hierarchical site lacation so
it's got nothing to do with um as far as
I can work out with the impact and as
the um supporter said you know there is
there is established planning permission
granted um and I find when I look at the
recommendation and this is the
recommendation in our repart that the
application ref few planning permission
for the following reasons impact of
character the conservation area I'd
argue that is minimal because it's not
in the conservation area and it's
outside is 55 yards away or 55 meters
away low level of less than substantial
harm to wh I mean we're into really a
very strange area here and it's for us
as as the man on the omus as we are to
have a look and see what is reasonable
and I have to say uh given what I've
seen so far and my colleague um
councilor mcro got his name correct um I
think he makes a very valid point uh is
there a benefit and the other point
which I'd like to bring up having sat on
planning committees for many many years
now how many times do I sit and I've had
no objetives and every member of the
parish and residents in favor of a
scheme I don't think that I think it's
the first so um just on that basis alone
you could say there is public benefit
there because the public have said what
they've said and you can't argue with
that and we are here to represent the
public and the public benefit clearly
has been expressed by the members of the
public so
um my view for what it's worth is I will
not be voting for the
recommendation Chief thank you chairman
and I don't want to turn into part of
the debate the permission which exists
here was arrived at I understand because
the only way to ensure that there was no
harm on the setting of
whistlecopter you know so I think CC
Barett you described that as as being
um being acceptable in some way it was
it there was no Heritage conclusion
around harm because it didn't didn't get
into harm at all so there was no
conclusion around that and whether it's
favored by officers no it didn't cause
harm and the planning permission here
exists only because at the time there
was an absence of five-year land Supply
and CS2 and cs1 are engaged they are
described in the conclusion of the
inspector as well as cs15 in relation to
landscape and Heritage
issues thank
you Council Parker you ready to
go yeah I
just this really is um I think this is
actually a little more tricky than um
than colleagues and ultimately it'll be
for for members to decide um how they
interpret that level of harm but
actually I would take issue with uh with
what councel Barrett says there about um
the inspector not referencing uh the
framework he absolutely does uh in in um
paragraph 18 that's the final paragraph
uh it mentions about the framework um
and because the proposal would conflict
with the policy of the framework this
provides a clear reason to refuse the
development so it's all about the
framework and I I assume uh we're now
with the updated framework with the
updated framework we're looking at I
believe Paras 200 and 202 and they're
quite clear that there must be a clear
public benefit um uh identified and with
the best will in the world um absolutely
take on board what what council mcro um
mentioned earlier but I'm not sure I I
can see that that's a clear
Improvement um in the uh in the you know
in the in the
application
um um technicality if you like it's an
improvement but I'm struggling to see
where the clear public benefit um of of
of of that lies so uh ultimately it's
for members to decide and as long as
members can justify um the their
reasoning um we we so be it but but I am
actually I'm a little bit uncomfortable
um with uh and I I at the moment um I I
will be supporting the uh the officer
recommendation thank
you yeah I think we're getting a bit
hung up on the inspector the inspector's
comments were related to uh a different
building in a different
location
um he came forward or she came forward
with uh a classification of a low level
of less than substantial
harm and identified some of the reasons
for that um finding which was the
location and the height and the
size well this application has been
moved to take it away from the harmful
setting it's been lowered and it's been
shrunk in size so to some extent the
applicant has actually complied with
exactly what the inspector complained
about with the first one and has
therefore surely come up with something
which is an even lower level of less
than substantial harm if there's any
harm at
all because they resolved what the
inspector was complaining
about at the end of the
day planning decision are all about
balance harm versus
benefit I think when you look at the the
picture of The
Proposal personally I can't see any harm
in the design I think it's a very simp
sympathetic and sensitively designed
building it will fit in with ch
chelsworth very well there's already a
permission to build on that site a
proposal of something which is not um as
attractive I don't think something that
wouldn't fit in as well with chelsworth
and therefore I could almost say that
we're only actually looking for a a very
small level of public benefit to
outweigh this whatever this harm is and
I would think the public benefit of not
having a building which is out of
character is sufficient to sway this in
favor of an
approval thanks approval um just to go
back back to councelor Parker's
quotation of the inspector's report
parah 18 because the proposal would
conflict with a policy of the
framework which is listed in footnote 6
well that was that proposal that
conflicted and our argument and my
argument I think in this instance might
be that because that uh proposal
conflicted with a policy in the
framework in footnote 6 it doesn't
follow that this one
does any more comments if not I'm going
to make one I I'm sitting here and I'm
I've heard the word harm used many times
and I have sat and heard this word
public benefit and I think we're
grabbing at stores to find one so I'm a
little bit conflicted um know that
anybody could explain to
me what they where where we should go
but at this moment in time I'm I'm
almost happy to support the officer
counc
Parker uh well I was going to concur
exactly with that um chair and I was
actually going to um to to force the
issue to an extent and um make a
proposal to support the officer's
recommendation see if I can get second
it I will second it from the
chair I'm allowed to aren I yes thank
you
was I
am yes councel BBY can I ask the the
proposers therefore of refusing to
explain the harm that they perceive this
is
causing well I would answer that chair
by saying that um I'm I'm not obliged to
do that we have the the uh the
recommendation is before us uh which
explains the situation um I'd back that
back immediately to council Busby and
say that actually the the owny is to
describe the public
benefit
I agree and we've heard the word harm Ed
so many times and and it's I don't like
the way it's described um i' much rather
it was harm was 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 but
being an engineer they won't let me have
that so I'm I at this stage would want
you to to put perhaps put that on my
scale for me but the at the moment the
the the public benefit is at the scale
of
zero sorry chair that's that is not the
case is it that any new building will
deliver
um a tax towards preset so there'll be
benefits to the whole of chelsworth from
them contributing
financially that just depends on your
starting point for
that par well only just to reply to that
say that we've got an extent permission
that would do that anyway chair than M
I'd just like to say that I think I can
see a clear benefit in
enhanced and improved design compared
with that extent uh permission now I'm
we seem to be being told we can't
consider uh the extant permission but
the reality of the situation is that if
one isn't built the only possibility is
that either no other possibilities is
either nothing will be built or the
extent permission will be built and I
don't see that the extent permission
being built is a benefit this is a
benefit I believe it's in much better
keeping with the environment in fact in
many ways it actually suits um that
particular special landscape and it
could be described as actually being
sympathetic in a way with the listed
assets so I think there is a public
benefit for
that thank you Mr chairman I think that
as this has been proposed and seconded
it should be put I don't think you
should be asked and at this St
to justify what what the harm would be
you consider the harm as sorry the
proposal and second to consider the harm
is there and they proposed it I think if
that's put forward and that failed to
win then it would be up to the committee
to decide whether they can come up with
the reasons to uh support it and put
forward the reasons of why they consider
there is benefit to the public I think
it's that way around rather than the way
yourself beer in terms of the fact that
we were still in debate we had a
proposal on the table once that debate
had finished that was where we were
going to move to yes I accept that Mr
chairman but you asked that we justify
or or that uh it was justify the reasons
for uh where the harm was you have
decided there isn't in The Proposal that
you've accepted and I think you should
put
it You' lost me there because I think I
was talking about public benefit not the
level but
if not we'll go to the vote go to the
vote can I get the chief planing officer
to just read out exactly what we're
voting
on it's it's the recommendation on
whichever page chairman sorry yes it's
the recommendation the application be
refused on page 141 um and officers will
uh take take that away and add the
appropriate policies thank you thank you
can I ask you open name thank you chair
members that vote is now in
progress
councelor Hinton did you need me to take
your vote verbally again it's gone
through now sorry thank
you thank
you so chair that's as councilor Jameson
is not taking part in the vote that's
eight votes against and two votes for so
that motion is lost okay now to move
on yes yes go chairman accepting that
there's been a discussion about harm
Council M quite interestingly made
reference to what he considered benefits
um the language that you're using is
important in these things if you
consider that ultimately actually we're
looking at this from the wrong end of
the telescope and that actually the
benefits are such that this would
conserve and enhance the setting of this
particular site and locality you're at
liberty to do that that's your judgment
to make everybody else has made their
judgment on the evidence they have to
hand that may be where your thinking
goes in relation to this as a reasoning
but clearly I'm going to need members
reasoning whatever they choose to
do since I've been put on the mark there
effectively yes that is my general
impression that I believe actually this
does enhance the the landscape the area
and the setting um in the context of all
the buildings along there um I think the
the design is sympathetic that sloping
thatched roof coming down to almost to
the ground I mean it's literally um I
believe it's been slightly sunk as well
um yes I find that entirely more
sympathetic than anything else I've seen
I can see why the planning inspector
refused the original application but I
do believe that that relative to all
other options is a public benefit and
that's with fely now how we address that
up in words obviously I will take
officers advice but that is my
impression and I believe that's the
feeling of much of the
committee well okay can we have canc I'm
happy to propose that that be the reason
given for approval Cas do we before
councelor H I'll second it you're in
second okay Mr Mr chairman um I also say
that I think if you look at what the
wording that the the inspector has used
bearing in mind that this was in
2019 and he quite liberally sprinkles in
the fact that we do not have a fiveyear
land Supply well we do now have a
five-year land Supply we have also seen
a development happen just down the road
almost adjacent to this particular site
so I think that the the impact of this
particular uh proposal will be less
less than less significant harm uh on
the conservation area or the the listed
building bearing in mind that it is well
separated from both of them uh and if
this had been a proposal to build an
extension to the listed building it
would have probably have gone through
without batting an
eyelid thank
you any more
comments well you're going to Define
okay conditions okay chairman you have a
proposal and and and a seconded motion
for approval um the earlier Planning
Commission has a number of conditions on
and it may be worth just rehearsing
those so that there is no uncertainty
about these things here chairman if
you're okay with that um and and clearly
we'd expect to list the plans related to
the application so that we get what we
see uh there is advice in your papers I
believe uh on uh ecology and following
the biodiversity um enhancement strategy
that's been provided so there are some
recommendations in there and a couple of
conditions which uh there was a similar
step taken with the earlier Planning
Commission so uh we would recommend
those uh given the location there's also
a recommendation that you um uh apply a
wildlife sensitive lighting condition
and that was uh a condition previously
attached to commission um
uh it goes without saying we'd also
expect to impose a landscaping condition
and a tree protection condition here uh
and to look to the removal of permitted
development rights um I think we'd also
ask for a condition regarding the
agreement of materials and for levels to
be agreed clearly scale is an important
thing here so ensuring that there is no
doubt about that will be useful uh and I
think the only other point I'd raise on
conditions would be uh regarding uh
landscape uh sorry regarding highways
conditions in the usual way to ensure
that there is parking parking turning
and access um uh laid out chairman thank
you okay
I'm content with all those conditions
could I add one that um the boundary
treatment particularly over towards the
Heritage assets be treated with
particular sensitivity um since there is
because that would reduce any level of
potential harm but obviously a screening
on that side would seem to be of of of
some
use you accept
that thank you can I surise
I'm just interesting we've got an
installation of a sewage treatment plant
as well but that's not been mentioned at
all in the presentation but in or in the
report apart from the description of the
development where is that going is it
just all below ground or is or
what sorry
Ken that will be a CL Clash is level
with the ground uh and the workings of
it are underneath therefore you get a
through flow and a down flow uh from the
house into the sewage treatment plant so
it is hidden from
view any more
comments if not have we got a wording
for the um you didn't want to go go over
it again you well I just are we are we
happy with the
wording okay we are subject subject to
the conditions mentioned by the chief
planning discussed by the chief planning
officer with the committee and with the
addition of the condition regarding
boundary treatment over to the Heritage
asset
sorry okay fine we will go to that
vote thank you chair members that vote
is now in
progress
thank you members uh so again without
councelor Jameson vote that's eight
votes for and two votes against that's
carried that's carried thank
you closed thank you we'll take a 5
minute break to allow you
to
everyone thank
you
we have the next application is land
west of sub Road
Acton and I think Elizabeth it's your
turn again thank you thank you so this
is outline planning permission for up to
30 dwellings including 10 affordable
dwellings uh with vehicular access to be
considered um as you'll see on your
tabled papers um it's been agreed that
um the only vehicular access will be
considered at this point and um
pedestrian access will be considered as
a separate Reserve matter if the outline
was
approved
so you'll you'll remember this from last
week's um site visit but this is the
site this is the main road through Acton
with uh long M for that end and going
towards great waling field this
end
again this is the site and as you'll
remember the the land drops so this is
the high point over here and it drops
this way towards the
road and this is um the indicative
layout um so you can see the vular
access here that would be part of what
you would um is to be considered at the
moment um and then there would would be
a road through the site um this all this
area here which is in the flood area
this would be um public open space uh
potentially with a play era there here
although that is considered in the
report and this would be a maintenance
track that would provide an a a way of
maintaining this hedge and it would also
provide access to the fields
Beyond okay these are the constraints so
so as you can see it's outside the
builtup area boundary which goes along
here um and then the other key thing to
note is these selection of uh listed
grade two listed buildings which are
considered to have the the development
would have a low level of harm
too
um okay this is a con connectivity plan
so this is to show how the um site would
connect to the facilities within the uh
Village I think the key facilities to be
aware of is the primary school
here um and the Village um open space
and um play Play area here Pub is are
here and the shop is around
here this is the proposed parameters
plan um because some of the or um the
site is within the area of surface water
flooding uh if you were minded to
approve this application uh we would
recommend that you included this as one
of the approved plans and this would
prevent uh residential development
occurring within the flood area so the
white area is all the flood area the
yellow area is outside the flood area
and this would be um and then res
residential development would be
constricted to just this area and you
can see the access
here right these are some aerial
photographs so you can see the site here
with the dwellings on mford road here
and the rest of the village in the
background again um it's quite a useful
photograph because this shows the other
two developments that have been improved
in Acton so this is tamage Road for 100
dwellings that's being built out now and
this is Barrow Hill up here again for
another 100
dwellings again this shows it uh looking
at it from Sudbury Road U sorry from
melord road so this is melord Road here
with the
dwellings um along the road this is the
site you can see sort of the slightly
wetter areas within the site uh and this
is the road to cuu Tha and you'll see
some photos of the development from this
end all right so these are photos of the
site this is looking up the site so you
can see it's high at the top and it it
falls de this
way again this is looking from Sudbury
Road into the
site the Hedge at the front this is
looking down subury road so the site is
on the left here this goes up to the
junction it's looking into the site
again this is just this would be the
area public open
space and this looks through the site
you can just see this is from melord
Road um and as you go along the melord
road you can see the site between the
the dwelling so there's one photograph
of it and here's
another then this is a photograph of the
listed buildings from subb road so this
is one to three subb road with uh the
old uh post office row behind and then
the other two listed buildings are
beyond
that uh this is
um photograph of the access so the
access would be in this location here
along sub
Road and again this is these are taken
from cobbler's way so this gives you a
good overview of the
site and there's another one of the site
this is from the sort of Mound at
cobblers away and you can see the
dwellings on melord road
here and this is taken from the road up
to kuu Thai so on this road and you can
just see those are the houses on mford
road and then this is the the sort of
planting around the the
site so it's been recommended for
refusal as set out in your report uh no
evidence of um local um Market need for
additional dwellings in Acton um is
considered that it's a detrimental
cumulative impact on
infrastructure um mainly on the primary
school as as um as these children the
children children Pro um within this
settle uh within the development
wouldn't be able to go to the Village
Primary School harm to the setting of
the listed buildings uh detrimental
impact on landscape character uh I mean
those are it's a a localized impact um
is only be viewed from local views but
it's considered that that the the
development of the the um Meadow would
be detrimental to the landscape
character of the area and then um with
it this is sort of just a abs of sign
section 106 agreement obviously if you
were remed to be approved uh we would
look to get a sign section 106 agreement
to include all the infastructure that
would
required thank you thank you Elizabeth
any questions for the officer
please Mary M
M Elizabeth I'm Jolly glad we did a site
inspection I think that was very helpful
can on the road coming from Subway where
does
the presume there's a 30 mile limit
where is that in relation to the
proposed site
access just before the site access I
believe I didn't go a lot of people
walked up there but I didn't
sorry in fact I think I was the only one
that walked up there and it's about
think it's about 40 m from from
memory was that above where you were
yeah okay thank you thank you
chair to that point actually I think
three members uh took the walk up to
that corner could we see slide four is
that
possible would be one right at the back
at the beginning of
course
uh yes that's the one so the access road
on the bottom um of there is actually
not at the extreme edge of the site in
fact it doesn't lie at the apex of the
curve of the road it lies a little bit
back so there's a clear line of sight
all the way down that street that access
but in the opposite direction the the
line of sight is um a little bit around
the corner before you actually reach A
straight piece of road and I would have
said the only possible point for an
access that would go both ways would and
I did a line of sight
check would have been um and I'm just
asking the officer if this if that that
is that has been checked because I've
looked at the line of sight and and it
it basically you need to be right next
to the very edge of the plot so you
literally have the access at that bottom
green bit on the boundary right
underneath the uh uh an electricity
Transformer on a
pole the access is in this location to
allow for the um maintenance track here
and to maintain the um the hedro outside
of the development um highways have
looked at the access and unfortunately
haven't included the access the planet
within this um and they have ex and
they're happy with the visibility
spays any more questions for the
officer no if not thank you
Elizabeth moving on we have a
representative parish council president
Mr gram rown you have three minutes to
address the committee Mr
round thank you chair Acton Parish
Council strongly objects to this
application and ask that you fully
consider all the issues raised by the
council and its residents the objections
details detail that this proposal
development is poorly designed and out
of character with the existing Village
setting there are more issues of concern
than I can cover in this short
presentation issues that should bring
the balance of scales crashing down on
the side of refusal the current emerging
plan and local plans and local plan
currently clearly place this application
site in the open Countryside the site
does not form a natural extension to the
existing resettlement the proposed
development will greatly harm an era
which provides the village of action
with an important connection to the
wider Countryside sub Road creates a
natural and well- defined boundary
between the builtup area of Acton and
the countryside breaching this strong
boundary would destroy an important
visual character of The Village another
important visual feature of the village
when entering from mford road is the
open Countryside to the rear of the
linear row of dwellings the current
backdrop of Open Fields creates a
gradual transition from open Countryside
to the built environment the proposed
development will destroy this important
visual characteristics and gateway to
the
Village the proposed development would
dominate both the landscape in the
skyline Andro destroy the far-reaching
views from existing clearly defined
perimeter of the village these important
public views will be permanently lost of
special importance are the setting Sun's
views from SRE Road these public Vistas
are an intrinsic to the Village setting
and must therefore be protected from
irreversible harm the existing blend of
Heritage and non-heritage dwellings at
subby Road and post office row on the
perimeter of the village form an
interesting and historic Street Scene
this proposal will dominate and
overshadow the setting of these unique
character dwellings consideration of
harm to the crown Public House a
Heritage listed building has also just
been completely been
overlooked both the council Heritage
report and the council's landscape
report do not support the application
The Proposal will will result in a large
intrusion to the open Countryside which
forms an important green area on the
edge of the village but delivers
relatively low number of dwellings for
the over sides of the intrusion
consequently it must be considered as
poor design poor use of Greenfield land
and a loss of important Green Space it
is impossible to IM mitigate the immense
harm this proposal will cause to its
surroundings placing even more weight on
the side of refusal The Proposal does
not bring any tangible benefits to the
community of action we respectively
request that the committee continues to
work with office officers to strengthen
the overall recommendation for refusal
thank
you any questions counc beer you wish to
answer question thank you yeah I think
this is actually to you Mr chairman are
we not um discussing um outlining some
matters reserved whereas we've just
heard um the parish council list a whole
load of things what are we actually what
are the S some matters reserved you know
because um some of the things he was
saying may not be relevant today because
it's outlining which is access and
perhaps the amount of dwellings but I
didn't think it was anything else but
perhaps you can so it's the I mean it's
the principle so the you know the um
Reserve matters would cover
Landscaping dwellings in terms of
because it's up to so potentially
numbers layout um and appearance but do
need to look at I mean this is the
principle of development so things like
the harm of the listed buildings the
harm on the landscape does need to be
considered at this point because if it's
considered unacceptable then those
reserved matters wouldn't you know you
wouldn't be able to overcome those at
Reserve matter
stage any other questions for the
parish
thanks carry on Mary I've got progam my
oh D not good is that want to missed
around
um one of your comments is about the
flooding and the on the sewage flooding
can you just um not too much detail but
is that yearly or twice yearly or
monthly or when it rains a lot flooding
in the area is regular I mean the
morning after the viewing party um we
sent a video into the planning officer
which unfortunately can't use um but
showing water pouring up out of the road
drains across the road completely
flooding the road where the proposed
Junction is so it's a normal currence at
the moment to see water coming up out of
the road drains um and and that drainage
system through the middle takes over
flow from two attenuation ponds an old
one and a new one and takes all the
surface water from the The Village so
you know in terms of um the impact on
that drain is system it's a capacity it
can't cope highways can't solve the
problem of water coming out of the
drains at the moment okay thank you
thank you thank you chair thank you any
other
questions no thank you very
much we have two objectives Mr Brian
mwin and Steve Lis um I hope I pronounce
it correctly if I haven't you you are
sharing the three minutes between you
and it begins
now good afternoon everyone my name is
Brian mcweeny I'm a resident of Acton I
live a quarter of a mile from the site
I'll be talking about the housing need
we welcome the planning Department's
view that there is no unmet housing need
which would justify approving this
application that conclusion is partly
based on there being a shortfall of only
four affordable homes between now and
2031 in fact we say there isn't even
that shortfill there's a surplus of 47 I
will highlight some points which are
thoroughly detailed in objections
submitted by the public there may be
debate as to whether it's the housing
need at the Village level or at the
functional cluster level which matters
here but the question is actually
irrelevant because on balanced analysis
of the overall data there is in fact a
surplus at both levels what we mean by
balanced analysis is for example if you
don't inexplicitly leave out 350 small
site windfalls from your supply side
figures if you don't inexplicably
suggest an income threshold of less than
35% at current policy giving the
impression that there's a range of
possible values for the affordable
housing need figure there isn't there is
a single value if you don't inexplicably
Place observations about local house
price to income levels on a small
selection of visitors Villages which
rank atypically high for unaffordability
but which only represent a third of the
relevant functional customers population
if you don't therefore conclude that the
average bab uplift should be applied the
uplift should in fact be lower because
the two functional clusters have lower
price to income levels overall than
babber as a whole for subur in great
cornard this inflates the need by 95
homes for every point that the up uplift
ratio is wrong by and it's likely to be
out by more than one point the
applicant's housing need report and the
data and conclusions in it should not be
accepted without scrutiny on its own
figures corrected where applicable there
is no unmet housing need which would
justify approving this
application good good afternoon my name
is Steve lree and I live in Acton I live
directly behind this proposed
development so was going to affect me
personally right my objections
are existing infrastructure is
inadequate to support this proposal the
poor citing the development entrance
exit on a blind bend the only access
route will be via the Crown Pub end of
sub Road this is a dangerous Junction
there's a 15in water M that bisects the
propos site this has not even been
acknowledged or accommodated into the
site's building plan the site and
general area have a history of serious
flooding with a water course and a very
large natural spring on site it has not
been demonstrated that the proposed Suds
will be effective against the 10year
cycle of historic deep water flooding to
the homes on S Road the ecology report
commissioned by the applicant's Messiah
information is incorrect and out of date
the case officer has has been made aware
of this point there are six protected
species present on site the applicant
has only considered mitigation for one
of these species all species listed have
been witnessed and photographic evidence
has been submitted the application does
not considered the harm to Heritage
assets the landscape setting that the
Heritage buildings were constructed in
will be lost heavy articulated building
delivery lores will have to travel past
and disturb the foundations of these
listed buildings a proposal that
includes the curtilage or settling of a
listed building must respond to
significant consideration the duty
imposed by the listed building act 1990
imposes a presumption against the grant
of Planet ambition which causes harm to
a Heritage asset thank you thank you
your time is up any questions to these
two
speakers no then thank you very
much moving on
we have no supporter so I will ask the
agent Mr Jack Wilkinson to address the
committee you have three
minutes thank you chair good afternoon
members I'm Jack Wilkinson planning
consultant acting four and on behalf of
the land owner this outline application
is for the erection of up to 30
dwellings of which 10 are affordable
with public open space and access in a
sustainable location without
demonstrable harms which all now go on
to discuss this site has history and was
part of the call for sides for the
emerging joint local plan but was only
emitted from the process due to concern
over flood and water there were no other
reasons the site has been subject to
rigorous stress tests relating to flood
and water and highways members what is
before you is a scheme with no technical
objections in respect to the outline
elements of this proposal unfortunately
the application is recommended for
refusal by your officers fueled in part
by questionable landscape and Heritage
comments the application has attracted a
number of unevidenced objections but we
can't please everyone and I don't think
the planning system ever
will this application therefore requires
a rational planning based decision
underpinned by the consistent approach
taken by inspectors at appeal level in
respect to
cs1 and and a logical assessment of the
landscape and Heritage impacts
particularly after your site visit last
week time and time gain cs1 has been
shown to be ambiguous in this instance
the long maford appeal is highly
relevant not just as a guide on how wide
to cast the local housing needs net but
also the cluster itself of which Acton
is part of the same precedent can be
taken from the tamish road scheme which
was approved by the council the way in
which cs11 has been applied at both
Council and appeal level cannot be
ignored and should be and should point
the proposal in favor of approval
certainly the benefits of this scheme
far far outweigh the harms the site
relates neatly to the settlement
boundary there is a proven housing local
need um as per the lichfield's report
Acton is capable of accommodating the
development with good spending power
which will assist local business open
space with potential for play
affordables enhanced landscaping and S
just to name a few to conclude the
location is sustainable the access is
achieved and the layout ear marked is
entirely in sync I appreciate the
concerns however when striking a logical
planning balance planning permission
should clearly be approved indeed there
are plenty of reasons to approve I'll
finish off the development plan may be
the starting point but it is not the end
point Thank You chair thank you y any
questions for the speaker h m uh yes the
report on page 152 um makes a suggestion
um on strategic housing um were the
committee minded to Grant The Proposal
would you be prefer prepared prepared to
accept the preferred mix described in
that
paragraph Yes we would I think the
comments set out I believe on page 152
have you mentioned that's the one yes i'
I've assess those and and we'd be happy
to to provide that subject to 106 and
there's also a half residual dwelling uh
set of a commuted sum that agreed the
commuted Su included yes thank
Youk you morning Jack um this flooding
and the sewage flooding is
really uh a hurdle isn't it if you how
would you reduce the effects of that or
what action would you take to prent the
proposed those buildings add to the
they're going to add to the whole thing
aren't they all these
houses of course I think this was one of
the key aspects that we looked at very
early on as I mentioned this part um
this site was was pushed at sort of
local plan stage but it was emitted on
flood and water ground so that from the
outset was going to be a key aspect you
know we're working with the constraints
so in terms of uh the surface water
management we've come up with a
deliverable and achievable scheme for
Suds and that's been endorsed by the
County Council flood and water um it is
achievable there are lots of different
clever um methods upon which to uh
provide these homes which by the way low
density so there's going to be plenty of
space to enable runoff rates to be
managed um through this site so from a
from a flood and water perspective our
Engineers are entirely happy the County
Council are happy and there's no
recommendation for refusal on flood and
water thank you Jack thank thank you any
more
questions thanks R thank you um the need
um I'm going to come come back to
because at the moment we've got two two
developments in Acton I will say I do
live in Acton um we've got two
developments in actum which is one is t
Road and the other one is barah Hill
which hasn't started yet so what why do
you feel that there is a need for more
houses just I I'd like to see where you
got it from and and how how is the
school going to
cope of course thank you um so in terms
of uh the need we firmly feel that there
is a need when you apply the methodology
that was used at inspector level so in
terms of um the long mford appeal that
cast The Net wider so not just act but
the cluster and when you assess it based
on the cluster there is a need in terms
of the calculation that that is run for
that it's a Well settled principle that
you take in developments that have been
approved uh and also developments that
have commenced now you're quite right to
my knowledge as well the tamage road
scheme is well out of the ground the
Barrow Hill scheme is not as to whether
that's going to be coming through and is
uh realistically going to start who
knows
so we have to base it on the here and
now and the here and now is that this
proposal would fill a gap in terms of
um the what was the other aspect of your
question again it was to do with um
infrastructure wasn't it sorry so in
terms of infrastructure and the pressure
that you've placed on school I I don't
dispute that there is pressure on
schools and you know healthc care
provision dentist and various other um
you know Provisions however that's not
necessarily the function
of the district council it's the County
Council but surely there's more you know
it's more important to have a place to
live as AOS to a place to go for at this
moment in time Healthcare or or whatever
it may be so it's a it's a fine balance
to strike um but I'd perfectly tell your
point yes if you
wish yeah I I I do understand where
you're coming from but you still need
the school places and the there's a lot
of a lot of children that um in certain
areas can't get a school place where
they live and being Acton I think you in
your own
village you should be entitled to a
school place you've got no doctors there
the only thing you've got is a
shop um bus service once an hour but it
it's still we've still got to think of
the tamage road area and things like
that thank you thanks row any more
questions for the agent councilor beer
uh yes um it's obvious you can't be held
responsible for the existant flooding
and series problems uh acting at the
moment um and your answers to my
colleague uh was are you satisfied that
the um
the uh remedial vs that you're putting
in on that site or proposed to you
wouldn't be adding to this problem
I'm completely satisfied and I trust
that the work the engineers have done to
calculate that um would ensure that you
know there wouldn't be a flood and water
concern as I said this was a key aspect
very early on and it's something that
we've addressed and taken seriously um
so no I've got no fear there and the
parameters plan that we provided which
the officer kindly beamed on the
presentation should give assurance that
we're not going to be building in or
near to that that surface water flood
zone area it's a low density scheme so
the built form would be located and
managed in the right spot for that
site any more
questions Busby can you bring up slide
four again please
Elizabeth um is there any you've got two
roads coming off on that corner one was
the maintenance Lane and one is the
entrance to the
site it is very tight having walked up
there you really need to be as close to
the corner as possible could you not
combine the two have one entrance and
have the maintenance Lane come off at
say I don't know 20 m in or something
off the corner the closer you get to
that corner the happier I I
feel of course and I take your points
entirely with respect to highways that
that point um we've looked at in depth
now the on sorry the slide's just gone
but on slide four um we've actually
furnished the planning uh officer with
uh an alternative uh site access so
effectively the access track that is
where the red marker is now would hook
and Link into the proposed access so
there'll be one access that would serve
the two needs one for the development
and one for the hedge row so there's
only one access
point
okay thank you very
much James did you
want uh yeah sorry sorry I was a bit
late there chair um the applicant you
you mentioned in the long mford appeal
but in the report it says here that um
spon appeal confirmed that for hint land
abilties a local need for Market
dwellings um related to The Village only
so what are your comments on that
and I think this is the precise quandry
that we're in you know C 11 is
ambiguous um you know you've got a
decision from long malford that captures
the cluster including Acton and you've
got a decision from the more recent uh
spren appeal that that isolates the The
Village um there's there's two scenarios
and I think the most relevant one and
possibly the most more senior one is
given that has recovered by the
Secretary of state is the long mord
appeal plus it includes Acton so there
is a gray area um I don't dispute that I
don't think the officer disputes that um
but on the whole we firmly feel that the
benefits firmly outweigh the harms hence
we're able to mount a case and an
application for you
today I think the chief planning officer
has a comment to make about that
particular
subject uh thank you chairman yes um so
uh long mford is a core Village in the
core strategy sporton is a hinterland
Village in the core strategy the cluster
concept applies to Hinterland Villages I
personally disagree with Mr Wilkinson
analysis and I would say to you that
cs11 is your guide and quite clear for
this uh clusters are what you look at in
Hinterland
Villages um don't think there's more I
can add here thank
you anyway thank you very
much moving
on we have award member present
councelor John none you have five
minutes to address
the the
committee good afternoon members uh this
is yet another application that is
outside the Acton settlement boundary
and is located within open Countryside
Acton is a hint land Village but is
making more than a reasonable share of
it of the new dwellings Acton currently
has 100 dwellings under construction
another site has permission for a
further 100 dwellings and yes a further
site has permission for five large
dwellings in fact the 2113 permissions
already approved or ex extended since
2018 represent a sudden 28% increase in
the size of the 760 dwelling
Village surely this already places more
than reasonable demands on the
infrastructure of the hinterland Village
this proposal is out of character and
does not relate to this distinctive
existing Heritage corner of the
village the village of Acton has evolved
along a cclass rural route and has no
safe pedestrian and cycle routes in or
out of the village Acton Village is a
hinan village it is isolated from
strategic transport corridors and remote
from Key
Services Acton has an over subscribed
primary school and relies on larger
settlements for a doctor's surgery or
dental
services the travel distances to these
Services seem to be consistently
understated in the applicants planning
statement we can't travel as the crow
flies the bus service is increasingly
unreliable as services are regularly
cancelled so any health or other
important appointments require cars even
the industrial estate which seems to
boost the scoring in the settlement
hierarchy is remote from and unconnected
to the
Village this application will bring
further unacceptable levels of traffic
to the dangerous Crown Public House
Junction the proposed new Junction for
the site will join sub Road at a point
where the Acton Community speed Watch
Team regularly records excessive vehicle
speeds this rural Lane is not regarded
as a 30 Zone by many driving
D the proposed new Junction is unsafe
and will result in an additional
dangerous Junction poorly designed and
poorly
located despite the conclusions of the
suff County Council highways I would ask
members to be bold and include these
highways concerns as further reasons for
refusal of further concern the creation
of the new Junction requires the removal
of a large section of long-established
rural Hedge
the existing hedge clearly defines the
settlement boundary of the village and
together with the water course running
through the site they form an important
Wildlife Corridor that should be
protected from
harm Mr lre spoke of the serious
flooding issue relating to the site and
flooding of the nearby dwellings he
raises concerns that these issues have
not been properly addressed the water
course running right through the site
provides surface water drainage from the
village and two attenuation ponds
overflow to this water
course the mo the morning after our site
viewing water was flowing up out of the
drains causing flooding where the new
access road is
proposed Mr Lou spoke of the wildlife
and ecology harm that will be caused as
a result of the proposed
development further demonstrating that
this important rural landscape is too
important and not suit for a housing
development of course the committee must
balance harms and benefits and so so as
such an application might be expected to
present an exceptional local benefit by
meeting severe need however Mr mcweeney
has already indicated under current
policy the applicant's own housing need
report shows a surplus of affordable
homes for Acton and its broader
locality with respect to the General
housing need there is no unmet need for
Acton itself and after Corrections for
emissions and locally inappropriate
projections uplifts there seems little
if any unmet need for the broader
locality housing need does not provide
good reason to support this
proposal the common impact of 243 new
dwellings on the infrastructure of Acton
is
unsustainable the application will have
a negative social physical and
environmental impact for the village
Acton is its Associated infastructure
simply cannot be expected to absorb
further 30 new
dwellings this unjustified application
presents a wide range of risk factors
and unacceptable downsides to the
community for the ward
member
no in that case thank you very
much open up the item for
debate anybody wishing to kick
off councelor
Barett um is this a sustainable
development because in the mppf we have
a presumption of sustainable
development
and I don't see it about being
sustainable in the
recommendations chairman I think it's
it's implicit that we don't consider it
is sustainable development because it
doesn't meet our policies and I think
there's a point of difference between us
and uh the agent on this we don't uh
make the point that it is sustainable as
we expect sustainability to be having
regard to cs11 and CS2 which are
upto-date development plan documents it
doesn't State anywhere that it isn't
sustainable there really does
it but it's not implicit is it what what
is what is definition of sustainability
so the definition of sustainability um
you because I think it's relatively
important so so you can start with the
nppf but for the purposes of of planning
decisions in vber you will look to cs11
and CS2 to get you to what is
sustainable development and we don't
consider that this development is
sustainable having regard to those
policies and I think whether it's stated
or otherwise I think that's our
conclusion
here um just to open debate I mean I'm
particularly drawn to the discussion
there already been and it's been
referred to by many people already about
local housing need and the report goes
to considerable depth and detail from
Paras 3.9 to 3.17
on what the definition in it is and what
we should be considering in reference to
Hinterland Villages various decisions
made elsewhere and I'm persuaded that a
lot of work's been done on that very
Point by officers I'm very grateful for
that guidance because I think otherwise
we could have spent a lot and will
probably spend a lot of time anyway
going through what the local need
actually is but it's quite clear that on
the cumulative impact that Acton like no
other h land village within bber except
for
brantham sorry what can I say when
you've got a percentage of over 25% on
your community size you have to say that
the local need Hinterland or cluster
it's just there's no question about it
there is not a local need so I'm quite
heavily persuaded on that point to
follow the officer
recommendation C
Parker
yeah I I'm I'm minded to um agree with
councelor McCraw on on that chair and
and just to sort of make sort of a
higher level statement that just because
Acton can absorb extra development it it
doesn't mean that it should um and and
we have a suite of policies um cs11
being the most prevalent amongst them
and I absolutely accept that um it's an
ambiguous policy and and and maybe it's
been sort of held up in in many appeals
but but equally it has been upheld um in
in many appeals as well um we have a
5-year land Supply um so the balance
isn't tilted um in in favor um of
development local need you've already
talked about um councelor nun um said it
absolutely that there's no unmet need
here um the development sits outside of
the uh the settlement
boundary
um in short it's very difficult to
justify that we actually do need we need
this development um and um why do we
have a suite of policies why do we have
a local plan um if we're if we're not
going to uh if we're not going to adhere
to it so I'm I'm probably minded to uh
agree with with with councelor mcro um
at this stage there's nothing if I might
sh that there's nothing exceptional
about this development I mean it's it's
30 houses that will add to uh to the
local housing stock um but Acton's had
its fair share um that in itself is not
a reason not to well not to support but
for all the other reasons I've given um
I think it is thank
you thanks just sorry there's there's a
lot of debate about cs11 being ambiguous
I'm I'm not convinced it's as ambiguous
as perhaps is being suggested here and
can I just be quite clear in the spoten
appeal that's been talked about we quite
clearly recognize that the function of a
core Village is to accommodate what
growth they need and growth within their
cluster the function of a hinterland
Village is to accommodate uh needs
within it and that should really inform
how we approach cs11
so you know that this is this is a
question what is proportionate what is
the nature of the village we're looking
at here so rather than trying to wash
wash smoke across the the issue I don't
think it's quite as ambiguous as perhaps
is being portrayed
okay any more
comments M thank you chair um nationally
we're being encouraged not to approve uh
planning applications where there is a
danger of flooding and I think this site
actually demonstrates there is an issue
of flooding um already and uh a new uh
development would only answer that thank
you bar um now that I had my answer or
my question answered by the chief
planning officer um and looking at all
the provisions and making it clear about
cs1 and the uh requirement of um the
local need um I
um can see that really we need to move
forward and I think that I would like to
propose we uh go with the recommend
recommendation that is on the uh
document here which is to refuse the
planning permission can I have a second
pleas second this all over the take
councelor Jameson
you wish to say anything or you uh no
I'm happy to second I agree there's no
local need I can say there's there's the
risk we could shipping children out to
other schools and and yeah I'm happy to
Second thank you any more comments if
not we'll go to a
vote you please take us to the vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress in your
app
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for refusal 11 votes for
refusal application is refused thank you
everyone poos to take another very quick
break while they rub the taable
down
they're far too busy consuming lunch to
worry about planning matters
um yeah right moving on land to the east
of Duke Street hindam um Council Busby
are you staying on the committee or are
you going to act as a war member uh no I
think my hand has been tipped in the
report so I probably better uh act as a
ward member rather than on the committee
they be speaking as a w member thank you
I will now ask the case officer Samantha
Summers to introduce please
thank you chair this application seeks
to vary conditions of planning
permission
dc18 05 613 for the erection of 14
dwellings garages and additional parking
at L the east of dukee Street hindam by
way of a section 73
application the application comes to
committee as it is considered to be
controversial the very varation of
condition would allow for the layout
design and mix of the housing to be
changed on the site and this would
include the removal of the affordable
housing
contribution this is the application
site marked with the hatched
area the application site is shown in
red uh development to the north includes
a housing scheme of eight dwellings and
also also a development of three
dwellings all dwellings have been built
and occupied Red House Cottages are uh
to the south of the site in this
location just
here the site is wholly within a special
landscape area the application site sits
outside of the builtup area boundary of
hosim but the principle of development
on the site has been established by the
granting of line planning permission in
2018 for 11 dwellings which included
three affordable units and a further
application was received in 2018 and
granted in
2020 uh which was for a full planning
permission for 14 dwellings that
planning permission is the one that this
section 73 application relates
to this is the layout of the application
site for the 14 dwellings that the
planning committee decided in
2019 the scheme was not policy compliant
in terms of affordable housing
contribution a financial uh viability
assessment was produced which included
this scheme for 14 dwellings but also a
development to the north uh just here
for a further three dwellings to the
north uh the the developer was actually
the applicant for both of those
applications um and therefore the
viability assessment was based on 17
dwellings in total not just the 14 of
the site that you're deciding
today the conclusion of the financial
viability assessment was that the scheme
would be viable with just three
affordable houses uh which would all be
provided uh to the south of the site for
14 in this area here
the developer decided not to purchase
the largest site in the end uh but went
ahead and uh built the three dwellings
in this area
here two access points uh were actually
included in this uh scheme for 14 one to
the north of the site just here and one
to in the southern half of the site just
here Duke Street has uh a very strong
linear pattern of development um and
this development followed that pattern
as you can see all of the houses are
just one
deep um the houses were quite modern in
their design uh which matched the
development further to the north of uh
this particular area
here these are some of the perspective
views provided uh with the last
application and these are those houses
uh that are actually built out uh which
are on the site for eight dwellings to
the north of the
site this is the proposed layout of this
section 73 application that's being
considered today we still have that
strong uh linear form of development
um that is distinctive in juk Street two
access points are still included uh one
just here to the North and the one to
the South this has been moved slightly
northwards uh from the previous
scheme all of the dwellings have parking
actually on their plots um and there's
additional parking opposite the
dwellings in this area just here
much of the existing hedge row uh to the
front of the site is to be
retained uh with some areas to be
removed within the visibility spays but
will be replanted further back in the
plot a boundary fence and hedro is
proposed to the north and east
boundaries the mix of housing has
changed all of the dwellings uh in the
previous scheme were for for two stories
there are now three bungalows suppos to
the north of the site in this area just
here uh the remaining 11 dwellings are
twostory there are five detached
dwellings um in the middle of the
site um and then there are uh six semi-
detached dwellings in this southern part
of the
site the mix of the housing has uh
changed in terms of the number of
bedrooms there's uh the in the previous
scheme there was a five bedroom dwelling
that is no longer the case and one of
the four bedroom dwellings has also been
dropped from the mix so now we have a
mix that consists of two four bedroom
properties eight three bedroom
properties which three of those are the
Bungalows and four two bedroom
properties the scheme does not include
any affordable units
um and therefore it is not policy
compliant a fin a financial viability
assessment has been received as part of
the application
submission that assessment has been to
the district valua for
assessment um the district Vala
concluded that with affordable units the
scheme would produce a deficit of
nearly with affordable a deficit of £
427,000
the scheme with no affordable units
would still produce um a deficit of
nearly
76,000 making the scheme only just
marginally
aviable the design of the
dwellings has changed and
um you realize you can't take part in
the debate I do realize
thank
you the design of the dwellings has
changed um and a more traditional
appearance um for this scheme has been
proposed uh this is a pair of the semi
detached dwellings uh showing three
bedrooms in the pink floor plan and uh
two-bedroom property in the blue there's
two lots of this
uh pairs of
sis this is a pair of the two bedroom
properties this is the detached three
bedroom to um there's three of this
house type on the
development and this is the four bedroom
detached dwelling of which there's
two this is the Bungalow
type um and again the same Bungalow type
but
handed um there's a very limited uh
materials palette for the development
which ties the whole thing together uh
and that consists of red brick uh
composite boarding pantiles and natural
slate the materials are widely seen in
Juke
Street
uh moving on to the photographs uh this
photograph is taken from the North End
of the site looking down uh towards Red
House
Cottages uh this one is looking back the
other way uh from the south of the site
up towards the new
development uh this is the pair of semi
detached Red House Cottages to the south
of the
site
uh these are some of the houses that are
opposite the
site uh this is the final uh slide that
I have for you um and this is Juke
Street itself with the application site
on the rightand side and you can see
that mature hedge row uh much of which
is to be
retained today members are deciding
whether to Grant A variation of
condition to planning permission dc1
1805 613 to allow for changes to the
layout design and mix of the 14
dwellings also included in this
consideration is the removal of the
three affordable
dwellings the scheme is not policy
compliant however a financial viability
assessment accompanied the application
and this has been checked by the
district valuer who has concluded that a
full Market Housing
Development uh was only marginal be a VI
viable and would result in a deficit of
almost
76,000 when measured Against The
Benchmark for
profit the existing planning permission
expires on the 25th of September
2023 however it is understood that the
developer would like to start on the
site early in the New Year the
archaeology conditions have already been
discharged there are some other
pre-commencement conditions that require
discharge before Works can start but I
understand that an application for those
is imminent a building regulations
application has already been
submitted it is likely that the 14
dwellings will be delivered quite
quickly the developer is a local Builder
who employs local people and it is
understood that during the pandemic uh
work has continued on their sites um to
build and also give Employment Security
to their staff the application is
recommended for approval to vary
conditions for Approved documents and
plans visibility spays refu bin storage
and presentation areas and
parking all conditions from the previous
permission would be carried over apart
from the archaeology which has already
been discharged these conditions include
uh a time limit for the commencement of
development Within in three
years members should they be minded to
Grant permission may wish to consider
changing the time limit to a shorter
time frame to ensure that the houses are
delivered
quickly if approved a deed of variation
to the section6 agreement would be
required to remove the affordable
housing element but still be able to uh
to have the Rams payments that are
required for the development thank
you thank you um any questions for the
officer councelor
Hinton simple question start things off
why should we approve
this uh the scheme already has planning
permission for 14 dwellings
um however at the moment it cannot be
built out to make a um viable profit
therefore the land May sit there for
some time and fall outside of the 5year
land
Supply Mr chairman yeah but what has
changed since the first planning
permission was granted they signed a 106
agreement for three affordable homes um
so obviously they must have thought that
they would still be making money out of
the site what has changed in that period
of time house prices are rising not
falling so uh there's a couple of things
that has happened the previous applicant
didn't want to go ahead and purchase the
piece of land uh so that has actually
changed hands a new developer is now in
possession of that land um building
materials have gone up there is a
considerable risk in borrowing money
against the development uh which the
developer is happy to take on that
risk c m um afternoon Sam um so in
essence if I'm not wrong here are we
we're being asked
to accept the loss of those three
affordable units and the commuted sum um
in return for what we believe to be a
favorable a better housing mix that's
the tradeoff essentially is it
not the housing Meek is better than the
previous scheme uh because we have less
of the bigger properties more of the
smaller ones but also uh some single
story dwellings which were not uh
included in the previous SCH
so in terms of the need in b as a as an
overall need that is considered better
um in terms of the loss of the
affordable units we never wish to see
that on sites but that in this
particular case is the tradeoff in
getting development started on the site
I just follow up on that that does that
fit the uh Market housing requirement in
hintlesham and area or is it just a
general housing need for Market
housing I suspect there will be some
need particularly for bungalows um in
hosam but that is the districtwide need
rather than hinam
itself thank you any more questions
Council
advis yeah councel advis but you're
acting as a ward member you're not part
of the committee at the moment if you
remember right that's very true so
perhaps you can't ask
question he can't he's he's act he's
acting as Ward member only he's not
staying as part of the do we I may need
to be reminded of our planning Charter
do W our Ward members allowed to ask
questions even not if they're not part
of the planning committee um he stood
down from that to be the ward member
okay fair enough
correct thank you any more questions to
the officer C coun just another money
one Mr chairman um if this site is so
borderline in terms of viability Etc uh
are we likely to get our s contribution
from
it we're going to have to go back to
court like we did with that one in long
mford was it or laven
orever okay so the financial viability
assessment did actually include the
contrib contributions to sell so they
would still be applicable in this case
it's just the affordable housing that we
would be
losing if not we'll move on we have the
applicant here Mr Dan Davis you have
three minutes to address the
committee good afternoon chair and
counselors my name is Dan Davis I'm a
director of landex limited the applicant
landex limited is an independently owned
company based on IP switch specializing
in the construction of new build housing
we employ 32 people and at any given
time we also have 50 to 60
subcontractors working across three or
four sites all of these people live in
babber and the neighboring districts in
recent years uh in the babber mids
districts we have completed developments
in Harley Boxford whatfield and Raiden
and they're currently building at Great
wenfield warit Stow Upland and ston
aspel all of these sites have fulfilled
their affordable housing quotas
producing 51 affordable homes 3 36 of
these units have been purchased by B
babber and mider District councils um we
agreed to buy the land to the EAS of
Duke Street in late
2020 uh at the time at the time we were
aware of wider viability assessment
which included the neighboring site to
the north um and concluded that three
affordable homes should be provided
across the two sites uh it was the
existence of this earlier viability
assessment that necess necessitated us
to instruct a further assessment to
accompany this application both our
consultant and the council appointed
District Val have concluded that it is
not viable to provide any affordable
housing within the proposed development
uh as the officer has stated in her
report we are Keen to um make a start on
this site indeed we've already submitted
a building control application uh in the
event that the committee vote to support
this um support the officer's
recommendation to appr approve this
application we'll be seeking to complete
a new deed of variation to the section
106 agreement discharge all of the
pre-commencement um planning conditions
early in the new year
with a view to breaking ground by the
end of quarter 1 or possibly early
quarter 2
2022 uh depending on market conditions
we' expect the development to be
completed within 18 months um I hope
that you're able to agree with your your
off officers recommendation um to
provide these new
homes um and I would like to state that
both um Phil Bron uh of win ke our agent
and I are available to answer any
questions that uh the committee might
have
in relation to this application thank
you any questions for the
applicant no thank you very
much right oh sorry just
one just the one I'm looking at the
changes in the 2018 approval um would
the increased profit from the larger
properties an extra three in sorry four
and five bedroom house not provide
enough viability given that this
involves the cost an increased cost in
building Bungalows which I think
actually is slightly more expensive per
square foot to build so they just a
wonder that doesn't quite square up that
you your housing mix is actually
producing producing fewer of the houses
that should make more profit um actually
yes um I I can answer that question in
fact the provision of bungalow has um
improved the viability of the site um in
our exper we we've got a lot of
experience building these larger houses
we started off as a as a niche Builder
you know building larger executive homes
um that market is very very tough uh the
the price per square foot that you'd
achieve for these larger homes has
decreased so in fact um yeah the the the
return on on the proposed Bungalows does
improve the viability of this game yeah
so in essence the marketability of our
preferred housing mix is greater than
the four and five bedroom houses that we
actually see mostly on most applications
I would agree with that yes
interesting any more questions for the
applicant if not we'll move on to be
addressed by the ward
member or aren't you going to address
it it would be a shame not to wouldn't
it
um okay
look I haven't really got a problem with
the mix of housing or anything really
the only issue I have is with the loss
of affordable
housing if you look at the site uh it's
one field it was one field was probably
one
owner there will have been 25 houses
delivered from that one field one strip
25 houses and yet no affordable housing
we should be looking at what eight and
we get none it's very convenient to
break the land up into small Pockets to
avoid having to comply with affordable
housing but here we've got one a scheme
that's supposed to be building 14
houses in a green field site where
archaeological stuff's been done a lot
of the work's been done how on
Earth can they not make a profit big
enough to uh to build affordable housing
we know that there according to the the
figures they'll be making a profit of a
million pounds which seems pretty good
but if we can't get affordable housing
out of a Greenfield site as simple as
this
one how on Earth can we expect anybody
else to come up with affordable housing
for
us I think we're creating a precedent
here of saying that viability can
be almost manufactured to ensure that we
don't get affordable housing I think
it's a very uh
worrying State of
Affairs it's not as though the site was
bought years
ago it was bought in
2020 with a a section 106 agreement on
it the purchaser knew this when he
bought the
site he knew what he was obliged to
provide which was three affordable
houses I don't see why we should lose
our affordable houses if he's
miscalculated his
Figures it's a it's it's a simple
straightforward site 14
houses three affordable I think we
should settle for that I'm afraid the uh
the developer should find another way to
make his profit I don't see why we
should lose out because he's
miscalculated thank you any questions
for the board member coun Jameson
uh soorry just I'm being may be being
dim here but you're saying the they're
still making a million pound up to about
a million pound profit they're
saying it's not viable so if there's
they they they could they not take a cat
in their profits you I being dim there I
I mean I'm used to using the figures
that are in the report which are page
178 which shows that with no affordable
housing then the scheme generates
$981,000
developers profit yes so so they 437,000
land value as well so you're looking at
nearly one and a half million pounds
that's coming out of
it yet we can't we can't have any
affordable housing if they're making a
profit why do we have this halfway
yeah I mean in principle I agree
entirely with with what um Council Busby
is saying there but I'm wondering if
that is entirely fair and if if we
haven't got the full the full picture
here now um I mean if we've if we've got
the applicant here I appreciate we've
gone through the questions but is that
not a question to the to the to the
applicant if we can if we can do that I
mean it's a very it's a perfectly valid
question is with due respect so you you
will have purchased or your business
would have purchased that that site
knowing that there was an s16 in place
um and it comes back to councelor
hinton's earlier question so so so what
changed um if if we can ask that um
because I sense that there probably is a
bit more more of a new wanted
answer I just I'll pick up on that um
yeah I think I think as as um as Sam um
started off the her her presentation the
um section 106 that stands at the moment
relates to two different sites it
relates to 17 units in total it relates
to the 14 site which my client purchased
and it also relates to another site to
the north which included three three
houses so that's the 106 includes both
those sites okay the three um the three
has been developed by the previous
applicant but they didn't end up buying
the 14 site that wasn't purchased from
the land owner from originally
and my current um client ising here
landex purchased that 14 site so that
106 isn't relevant hence they they had
to relook at the viability and they had
to revisit revisit the scheme and hence
the application came in so so so the
three units that were related to the 106
as it stands relates to two sites which
landex aren't developing so that that
kind of hopefully answers that question
so so the viability had to be rerun it
had to be rerun because it's only 14
dwellings rather than
17 um just to pick up on one of
councelor Busby's points if I if I can
is
if the um regarding the development of
the whole site in 25 units will actually
the first eight units that were
developed provided you with three
affordable homes you've got them that
already has happened so so so that site
has provided some affordable homes
already in that case if they can do it
sorry this is this was my spot which was
a question towards the council towards
the
counselor if somebody can provide three
out of eight why can we get why can't we
expect any out of
14 it's it's a different time the
viability is there to test the market to
test build cost to test the afford
affordability of the site and the
viability of the site my clients run
that test um and your Consultants have
run exactly the same test and they've
concluded the same thing that this isn't
viable with affordable housing in terms
of profit the the calculation the
viability assessment calculation allow
a developer to have a profit of 15 to
20% they're a business they need to make
money so and that that calculation has
been made and it's been punched into
into the report and the viability
assessment um and the outcome is that
any affordable aren't viable if if there
was no profit to be made on this site
then a developer wouldn't do
it any more questions to the ward member
which may be deflected
elsewhere no thank you very
much
right debate councelor Hinson do you
want to start off I'd like to start off
if I may Mr chairman by a a question to
our legal advisor if the S s106
agreement was on 17 houses 14 plus three
uh and it's now been split into two
sites one of 14 one of three and both
are getting away with doing absolutely
nothing uh who's liable under the s106
yeah happy to deal with that chairman
the I I don't I have it wasn't me who
dealt with this 106 I'm relying on what
I've been told if if there's a section
106 agreement that relates to 17
dwellings then a split in ownership
doesn't it the the the the planning
obligations in the section 106 run with
the land no matter who buys it
subsequently um that happens
automatically under the planning
legislation so the um the the not unless
the deed says otherwise and it would be
unusual for to do so the whole of the
site is bound by all of the obligations
and but it's is being said to you as a
committee that it's you're being asked
to remove the obligation because you're
being advised it's not viable so that
that's the point it's binding at the
moment but you're being advised that
it's ought not to be anymore because of
the viability issue if that's none of my
planner colleagues are disag with us I
don't
think we'll just check with the chief
planning officer um there's nothing i'
gain say about what Mr depra has advised
you just so we're clear here the nppf
advises that the weight you attach to
viability appraisal is for you as a
decision-making body bearing all of the
circumstances of the case in mind one
other thing here I think this section
106 is less than five years old is that
correct Sam um
we are not obligated to vary that
section 106 if we do not choose to um
our calculation as officers to you is
that the value the worth of of promoting
the economic
activity is a merit um but it's entirely
a matter for you to weigh and the
section 106 bites and runs with the
Landers Mr said so there's no getting
away from this and this
application is in a a matter of choice
thank
you I may Sherman just to members might
appreciate me the point about the five
years is after if an obligation is over
five years old the applicant the owner
land owner can make a formal application
to vary or modify or discharge the 106
and if we say no they can go to a
planning inspector but that option isn't
available if it's less than 5 years old
they have to we we can vary the
agreement if we choose to but other in
this case there's been another planning
Act of section 73 application to achieve
the same aim
clearly thank you C I've just been doing
and I wonder if I could ask for
officer's advice on this because it
concerns the valuation and what's been
called the residual land value so
looking at the tables on page 178 the
top one shows the original one including
the affordable housing with a gross
development value at do I can I allowed
to use the figures in their open public
four
7 uh so 4.7 million less gross
development costs over 4 million now
here's the point a an assessment is made
on the suitable developers profit
therefore somebody has calculated what
that profit should be theoretically and
that calculates out at 18.8% on the
gross development costs leaving a
residual land value which is the
difference between the gross development
value the less gross less the costs less
The Profit leaves a a loss of
12,177 over this notional profit but
that notional profit still shows an
18.8% profit margin or return on the uh
costs now the proposed um Amendment with
no affordable housing leaves um a
residual land value of
43773 that is £
43773 more pounds than the calculated
suitable developers profit and there the
suitable developers profit is calculated
at
2,29 which I calculate to be
23.4% on the gross development costs
seems to me that the developer is
gaining the suitable developers profit
at a much higher level the residual land
value is a much higher level although
I'm not quite sure that seems to me to
be potentially additional profit so
effectively I can take councelor Busby's
Point very clearly I can see clear
reasons for a potential refusal in
this comments from
anyone no in that case can I have
proposal as
the cas well only only in so far as to
say um and I've always got the highest
level of respect for for councelor mcra
but um you know you you you've done
those figures on your bit of paper there
um as opposed to a district valuer who's
who's you know come to so I'm not sure
that we can I'm not sure that we can
take that at
Absolute face value I'm not sure that
we'd use that as a basis for a
recommendation is what I'm is what I'm
thinking I'm not disputing that what
what what you've come up with I'm just
saying can we use that as a as a as a
base for you know supporting a
recommendation on
there that is what's contained within
the report that we've been given for
determination if it wasn't supposed to
be suitable for making a determination
we shouldn't have been provided with it
um and it comes from the financial
viability assessment fva so I have to
say that we have to take what's put in
front of us in the report and I've
double checked my figures and um I think
my analysis is a reasonably accurate one
perhaps the officers could
comment Sam says you
go um yeah could I just point out that
those tables that you're looking at were
from the financial viability assessment
that was produced with the application
that has been looked at by the district
valuer and on the next page are his
conclusions so you
know the district valer did actually uh
when he looked at the assessment it
showed a better
position uh than what was shown on those
tables however the district valer still
felt that there was a deficit in profit
for The
Benchmark with no affordable dwellings
which is why we've have um recommended
approval of the
scheme CH chairman I mean just just so
we're quite clear what's going on here
you have a choice and it is a choice um
your policies do expect affordable
housing provision and you know that's
clearly what's being lost here um I
think the advice from government is that
viability is for you to weigh up as As
You Wish and you know you have have a
defensible position in that you could
sit there and say well actually it's
more important to us to seek a a
developer who will secure these
affordable dwellings the question is
whether the construction imperative here
that we as officers have put forward as
being the reason for saying yes is the
point that um weighs with you but you
know as as usual committee is not there
for the simple applications committee is
there for the difficult applications and
um this does post that fundamental
choice between priorities and the
section 106
we don't have to change as a council it
sits and runs for five years from its
creation chair sorry do you mind if I
I'm afraid
not can discretion
to well what were you going to tell us I
I just want to point out just pick up on
on the calculations that are in the in
the report this is like like Mrs Summers
has said this is an extract out of one
of the document and one important figure
that is missing here is is the is the
site value or the site cost it's not not
less development costs that needs to be
plugged in as well so so so the figures
there you can't just look at those in in
uh out of context basically need to
review the whole report thank you Sam
can you
comment uh not really apart from I'm not
a viability expert which is why we
actually consulted the district valuer
on this because it is a very complex
subject to try and understand thank
you counc par yeah okay so I mean even
if we um even if we considered um
Council Moss some calculations you know
it's an extra 5% of of viability what
does that provide for us in terms of
affordable um housing units in any event
so I kind of think that we we we're in a
we're well we're not in a headlock it's
entirely up to members isn't it as the
chief planning Officer says if if
members say that we we we've got to go
with um uh or well we can we can make
our own decision um but it seems to me
that to a certain extent we are in a
little bit of a headlock here actually
um I I can um I can absolutely see both
sides of of what is being proposed here
but the alternative is if if we uh if we
don't allow the variation of the section
106 um I mean I could do with some
guidance here but what are for example
hypothetic scenario could the developer
withdraw this application and then
submit for for nine houses we get no
affordable anyway makes the game even
more viable um but we we end up with no
affordable I mean as it stands we're
getting a seal contribution here and we
are getting the land developed um it
occurs to me that we we're in danger of
allowing this land to sit there and go
fallow for years um whil we decide what
happens thank you well I was going to
make a similar point I mean what is the
loss to the district if we um don't
follow the officers recommendation what
what is the downside for
us yeah I've done some new calculations
on 3o R just to just to please everybody
um so the considered an independent
opinion um on the basis of The Benchmark
site value adopting what's called an auv
approach which is also the case
previously is that the site value should
be 850,000 and that's in both cases the
difference in the the um affordable
housing scheme and the um basic scheme
that is now being proposed is £350,000
995 and I believe that's the question of
where the viability actually lies okay
so if we can still take the um figures
of the suitable developers profits as an
indicator and I'm not sure it isn't
exactly right but broadly speaking it's
it's making and I'm I'm going to confess
I'll accept this because uh 350,000 out
of
774 is a fair old bit it's over
400,000 okay um is left so I concede
that point just thought it's meant worth
having the
figures um yeah thank you chair I'm
again as I did this morning I'm going to
force the issue and um propose that we
um accept the officer's recommendation
thank
you
McLaren wish to say anything or just be
the
second thank
you we
have there's no more comments we will go
to a
vote I can ask you to conduct the vote
please claim thank you chair members
that vote is now in progress in your
app
thank you members chair that's five
votes for and three against that's
carried so the motion is carried the
application is approved thank you
everyone he's going to give me a bloody
crooky my neck
me S thank you Simon okay thank you very
much much we'll we'll we'll move
on we're back to full strength welcome
back all and we're moving on
to
the we're back to to the slaughter house
and land adjacent to cooku Hill and
Heritage compliance team either Simon
Bailey will explain the
problem
s over to
[Music]
you thank you
chair uh so um the matter before members
today is a further revision to the
uh section 106 obligation that was um
alongside the application to um amend
the approved scheme for the development
at cooku Hill in
buers um if members recall this was
before you back in July uh as an
application to change the uh the
approved scheme for plots five and six
of the cooku Hill
development um you granted that uh
subject to a section 106 agreement that
required a bond to be secured by
developer to the tune of quarter of a
million pounds um Unfortunately they
were unable to achieve that so uh the
matter was brought back before you in
August uh with an amendment that was for
a deposit of £130,000
cash and a exchange of the title to the
two properties if uh the developer
defaulted um on The Works to complete
those two properties in accordance with
the scheme that was the revision um uh
and you resolved to approve that as well
uh unfortunately we're now in a
situation where they need a further
revision to the section 106 um terms
because uh they've taken out a a
mortgage on the two properties uh which
means that they won't be able to achieve
the the wording that's in the resolution
which is that the title will be
transferred to us free from charges and
incumbrances
so uh what what we're proposing uh
before you today is to change the
wording so that it is subject to a
charge um in the name of Mt Finance who
are who are the mortgage company that
have um provided the finance for the two
uh
buildings um but otherwise to still to
still uh secure the £130,000 cash
deposit with us um for the duration of
the of the build um and for that for the
title to be transferred to us if they
default subject to that charge so the
mortgage company retains their security
um and has their their money back back
um and for us to then be able to use any
um further Equity to complete the
properties and then uh sell them to
Market um obviously that's only going to
uh have any effect if they default um
our understanding at present is that
they
are uh partway
through um Works to the building to
achieve the Revis scheme th that partway
through being sufficient to uh
demonstrate some compliance with the
enforcement notice that was uh on the
two properties um but only so far as
they needed to go in order to then do
the works that were subject to the
revised
permission um so essentially they've uh
taken the roofs off and reduced the the
walls down to the height that we
approved subject to this 106 agreement
so they are now uh subject to this 106
agreement being approved and the um
permission being issued they are in a
position to proceed with the rest rest
of the works um and then uh put the put
the two properties to Market assuming
that we go down that
scenario um there would be uh no need
for us to have the title to the two
properties and the 13,000 that they are
ready to deposit with us would be
returned to them um hopefully that would
then be cuu Hill
resolved uh any
questions any questions members
canel be kick off um thank thank you Mr
chairman uh can you just answer to me
are we any worse off or are we out of
pocket as a as a result of this if we
follow the proposed course of action
that you're suggesting because it seems
terribly complicated now uh backwards
and forwards uh so I've got to rely on
on what you're saying I wasn't happy
when it came to us last time I'm really
not happy with it this time but are we
any worse off the same or potentially
will we be out to pocket at the
end uh well based on what what we know
uh we we don't think that there's a
significant risk to the Council on the
basis of this
change um they're still going to deposit
the £130,000 to us uh in cash for the
duration of their their
build um if that uh if they default uh
and they have to give us the vital we
think there's sufficient equity in those
two buildings based on market value from
an estate agent uh that there would be
sufficient equity in those two buildings
to pay off the mortgage and give us um
funds to be able to complete those
properties if we needed to and then sell
them on the market and not be at a
loss I move the
recommendation thank
the beer any more comments anybody makes
make councel mcro just one thing um so
we would be undertaking in that event of
default they we would be undertaking the
mortgage but we would have the Freehold
in which to pay off that mortgage but
we'd have to do something like sell it
sell it
presumably that's where if there is any
risk Well we'd have to repay the
mortgage
uh yes if you like I mean I my
understanding is that we wouldn't
um uh yes I think we we would have to
pay off the mortgage out of the equity
that was in the properties once they'd
gone to
Market
speak I'm if I get any closer to the
microphone I might be on top of it but I
I'll try um as I understand it that we
would when we if we were to get the
title to the two properties we would
then have to pay off the
mortgage um and then use any remaining
equity in the properties to try and
complete the
works but this is only in the event that
they default the indication from the
developer is that they're going to
proceed to
completion if I can help chairman yeah I
I quite totally endorse my colleague's
comment if I may chairman yeah um the
the only risk to the public purse would
be if well for a as Simon Mr biley says
a lot has to go wrong before we invoke
these Provisions if God forbid it does
we um acquire the title to the two units
um and we've already had the benefit of
the deposited money to use and we would
the only difference you're being asked
for approv today is that we we live with
the mortgage they've entered into to um
recently and so we would then the only
risk to the public purse would be if the
Sal value of the two units did not cover
the mortgage and any additional costs
that were not already paid for in
£130,000
and it is judged by officers and I I can
see the sense that that that is appears
to be a very low risk at
present just on that point though we
would presumably have to complete the
property first before we could go to the
market and then pay off the mortgage
that would be the order in which it
would take place yes so yeah so this so
covered for all of those things but I
think it's important to get the
order what happens if we don't accept
this sorry what happens if we don't
accept it uh if we I'll go if uh if we
don't if we don't accept this resolution
then we don't grant them the planning
permission and then we go back to the
enforcement notice and they're required
to demolish them if they if if we go
down that route the indication from them
is that they will then lower the ground
level that they raised when they did
these builds and then they would build
out the original
permission um of eight and a half meter
houses so uh the reason that we are
continuing to pursue this is that we
think this is a better scheme than what
they got originally and this is going to
have uh less of an impact on neighbors
and uh The Wider
Community thank thank chairman if I if I
can just say yes
the the potential here is you end up
with a scheme which we as officers
advised you we didn't think was
better um if all of those things fall
into place and don't forget this is
about a fallback to a situation and we
have 13,000 to continue the works that
they've already started uh sitting in a
in a deed which is ready to go um the
equity here we believe is sufficient to
cover what would what it would take to
finish the works off um I think our
advice to you is there is limited risk
can't rule that out but it is
limited okay we have a proposal in a
second I propose to go to the vote I can
ask Claire to to set it all
up thank you chair members that vote is
now in
progress councelor be can I take your
vote please I was against last time I'm
against this time thank
you thank you members chair that's nine
votes for and one against nine for one
against thank you very much application
is
approved can I ask canor Parker to
rejoin us if he wishes only if you
really want
[Applause]
to I wouldn't have eaten it
all
right
right okay we'll ask you formul in a
moment okay
bloody
M okay moving on to Brandon and um
Council mcro you've indicated that you
wish to stay in the committee for this
particular one thank you very much I'll
invite Rose Wen to to introduce the
application this application is to
modify a section 106 planning obligation
for B1
15263 brantham industrial State Factory
Lane
branam
sorry uh this presentation is to provide
illustration and should be considered in
conjunction with the associated
committee report which you all should
have um been made available to
you the amendment to the section 106 is
ass associated with the previously
approved application as mentioned
previously by way of deed of variation
the amendment sort are in relation to
the paying of a fixed sum as an overage
contribution to the district council and
subject there to the removal of schedule
3 from the original agreement I would
like to remind members that this
application does not involve any
amendments to the development itself
only to the section um
106 uh this is just a brief reminder of
the site and what was approved the area
in pink is the site which is on south
and east side of
branam uh this is the approved master
plan the application was for a hybrid
application for the Regeneration of
existing industrial State and
development of the adjoining land uh
with outline permission of mixed use
development
comprising approximately 320
dwellings uh
44,1 123 square meters of class B1 B2
and B8 employment use as well as
provision of public open space and new
playing
pictures and full permission of a new
access from Brooklyn's Road improvements
to factory Lane New on-site Road Network
and structureal Landscaping as well as
fou and storm water drainage
infrastructure uh the application was
granted in November 2016 and has
commenced uh you can see the dwellings
on the North side there and the
employment space on
South schedule three of the current
section 106 agreement contains an
overage provision the overage proportion
that is due to the council is
45% of any gross development value
Surplus generated over a period from
consent to the final review the final
review being the date of the 2 first
sale to the sale of the 288th dwelling
the residential development is not
expected to be completed for several
years hence it will be a long time
before the final outcome of of the
overall viability of the development is
certain this is due to the housing
market being liable to change
the applicant is seeking to negotiate
the Surplus to be paid with a one-off
payment to be made now the payment
offered has been calculated on the basis
of the consented residential scheme and
agreed with the district
Bala a viability appraisal has been
undertaken and shows that the scheme has
been calculated to generate an
anticipated surplus of 3,
59,2 51 PS given that schedule 3 of the
current section 106 agreement states
that the owner will pay to the council
45% of the Surplus by way of an overage
contribution the predicted amount due to
the council is
1,579
163 which the developer is offering to
match to be paid now rather than an
uncertain amount at the end of the final
review in several
years there are are advantages to
accepting the sum now rather than an
uncertain sum at the end of the final
review one is that it is a guaranteed
sum now the risk associated with the
potential future fluctuation in the
housing market will be removed whilst
there is some potential loss of
opportunity of further
Surplus it is considered however that
this is unlikely to be
significant the outcomes of the
viability reviews contained in this
section 106 are also still a way off and
the outcome is unknown there is no
guarantee that the council will receive
the same sum offered
now the Surplus may increase but equally
May decrease and finally the settlement
of the Surplus at this point would
enable the council to access funds
without delay and to program at spending
plans using that now rather than later
bringing forward the opportunity to
deliver with these funds at an early
time
should also be noted that the council
faces an acute affordable housing
shortfall unrelated to the overall
housing land Supply position if agreed
the council will receive a substantial
sum to put towards immediate affordable
housing
projects and the recommendation is
approval thank
you thank you thank you
Rose when the light comes up I can read
people's names um any questions for the
officer
no and thank
you if I could have a question to the
legal advisor you can um
this this proposed
uh paying the the overage up now rather
than waiting till the 288th house has
been sold and all the rest of it this
wouldn't have anything to do with the
applicant being sub to a takeover bid
would
it liabilities no direct knowledge of
that myself I'm afraid
I chairman just from my perspective this
this matter has actually been in hand
for a little while so I don't know how
long any takeover questions have be
coming around I suspect they're perhaps
more recent but this has been this has
been running a little while already as a
request re to suppose that was that just
speculation okay no it's in the
marketplace thank you and and any
questions no yes again thank
you well just we've got what the maximum
payment would be which is nearly 5
million but what we don't know is what
we think the payment would
be I don't know how much we're giving up
by accepting the one and a half
million I know there's a big gap between
1 and a half million and 5 million but
what and about 3 and half million yeah
than thanks I'm glad you're in charge of
Finance um but I don't know what what we
would expect under normal circumstances
the 45% to
generate uh if you uh if I could refer
you back to the report um the viability
appraisal that was undertaken did show
that the um the calculated um
anticipated Surplus would be
3,925
1 uh at the moment so 45% of that is the
sum offered
today CH one one other point just while
brose was answering that as well I mean
obviously we have
um we know what we've got here because
we're seeing a development of 288
dwellings not the 320 that was
originally you know part of the
proposition So to that extent you know
this is there is uncertainty but we know
what we have to quite a age and it's 1,
579,000
sorry to inter I can provide some
clarity on on councelor hinton's
speculation this is money coming from s
Francis group not the uh builder of the
houses if there's any confusion there
this is from the original applicant who
signed the section 106 agreement um all
I'm going to say is this has been sort
of the preoccupation of the last eight
years of my life this site and as
mentioned 300 20 houses proposed many of
you members were involved in that
decision We've Ended up with
288 because this was strategic site that
no affordable housing component was
included whatsoever zero uh not from Zer
out of 14 Z out of 320 or now
288 now uh given all that the impact has
fallen on bransom I'm in support of I
taking the 1 and a half million whatever
the figure exactly is but I would like
to request very strongly that uh now
that that money would be under our
control it's a discharge of a um section
106 agreement discharge therefore the
money is under our control and I'd like
to request very strongly that that money
be uh ring fenced for use within bransom
uh preferably with a considerable amount
of um Branson local uh connections
because frankly it's Branson that's
taken this massive increase of over 25%
as referred to in one of the earlier
reports we heard today and I'd just like
to ask if officers can make some sort of
commitment towards looking at that in
principle um as being a sort of matter
of I would supposed to say natural
Justice and I would hope any me any Ward
member in my position would do exactly
the same because bransom has taken a lot
of houses and received virtually no
affordable housing till recently where
is coming up and that's only because
babber are developing
it so I'm happy to support this do like
that that sort of assurance I get Chief
might have to respond to you thank you
chairman and I think Rose has looked
into this with colleagues in our
strategic housing team because it's it's
a challenging ask and I don't know Rose
if you've got anything you can add to
kind of discussion that has got us to
this point around where strategic
housing are because effectively planning
won't be spending it this goes into what
strategic housing look to
achieve from a discussion with strategic
housing um the funds would preferably be
spent on additional units um which could
be uh in Bram but there would uh if but
that would only be if there was an
opportunity and a need there um but
equally there needs to be a
consideration for opportunities
elsewhere and babber um at the moment um
the Gateway for Home Choice voice shows
that there are there's a 98 week wait
for affordable homes in Bram but other
places in the districts such as um
ashington and Newton they have 148 week
weight I'd say it's fairly marginal
however I'm I'm asking for as bransom to
be given what we would call a fair a
fair crack of the
Whip and I would like that if possible
recorded in the committee's decision
whatever proposal we
make chairman I without tying the hands
of the decision here and creating some
cumbersome process would it be
sufficient for officers to take that
back for myself to take that back to the
housing team and to stress the
importance of uh uh looking at what can
be done in branam as a as a priority and
seeing how that can be achieved if that
can be achieved as Rose says with some
degree of opportunity and and present
need accepting that if we can have
opportunity elsewhere we might look to
do that it's not as though Market
housing isn't indeed being built in
Branson right
now any more comments
questions now for
Rose and then we'll move into I think
we've already started debate
accidentally but on the
other uh can I just say it's interesting
isn't it that the
um the viability appraisal seems to
suggest that the profits growing over
the last 12 to 18 months whereas in
hentam it seemed to suggest the other
and I think it's a shame that we didn't
come up with a compromise on hintlesham
with an overage like we have
here we we've thrown away about
350,000 towards affordable housing by
going with black and white I'm
disappointed that the officers didn't
come up with a an overage scheme on
hintlesham rather than just cave
in I'll get the chief man officer to
respond
I I I
think I think chairman there's there's
probably a fine conversation about how
we approach viability cases and the
world is a continually moving Target
around some of these things the question
of overage in my experience is always a
a a thorough nuisance to try and
calculate and people you know you end up
in my accountant versus your accountant
so yes theoretically I I think there is
some attraction to it it's a it's a
compromise to be honest you know the
black and white compromise if you don't
like something refuse it is is just as
just as
credible and any more
comments if not can I have a
proposal for the
motion have we got
one bar councel mcro second yes thank
you can we can we have a provision in
the decision or is it just a binary
thing you know can we have a decision a
a mention a provision within the
decision that Branson be given
preference for the spending of that
money off to respond to that and then
we'll I was just going to say Mr
chairman uh I was always impression that
when money came in like that it was for
the whole of Baba District it couldn't
be ring fenc any particular Village they
try to start with but if they can't
spend it there then they spend it
outside and uh if they couldn't spend it
there how long do you want them to hold
on to to
L it's only a million and a half Peter
and I'm just suggesting that it would be
reasonable given 3 288 houses yeah I'm
sure you'd feel the same if it was in
great
cornard we can't CH chairman we I I
wouldn't I wouldn't suggest you should
for the reasons that Council beer has
described what I will do as a commitment
personally to council MRA is look to set
up a conversation about that with
colleagues in housing so that at the
very least the question of the art of
the possible has has somebody to take it
away and
discuss
okay okay we have a proposal on the
table can I ask the government's officer
to take the vote thank you chair members
that vote is now in progress Council
beer thank
[Applause]
you
everybody
Ved
okay councelor Osborne would you like me
to take your vote
verbally okay thank
you
thank you chair that's 11 votes for
that's carried 11 votes for that's
carried application is approved thank
you much for your attendance and
patience um the next meeting will be on
the 5th of January um I now formerly
closed the meeting and wish you all
health during the break until the new
year